[Music]
great i think we are live uh welcome
everyone out there uh in julia land i'm
really excited to be organizing this
julia molson mini symposium this year um
and and thanks a lot to everyone who's
who's contributing and listening and and
has helped organizing behind the scenes
um so it would not have come together
without everyone's help so so really
really grateful for that um i'm dr
rachel kirchen i'm a postdoc at carnegie
mellon i'm actually starting a research
faculty position here in the fall um and
i'm i'm really excited to be sort of
emceeing today and and
taking up the first bit of the
presentation time um so the first little
bit of this is just meant to be sort of
an introduction and overview so um
hopefully folks can see the uh the
comments um and so i've posted both uh
the pigeonhole link for any q a
so i'll be monitoring that um if you
have any any questions for discussion
we'll we'll have some uh some time
blocked off at the end of each at the
end of each presentation to to address
any questions from the audience so uh
please direct those there and i've also
posted the link to
the organization website um which has a
link to both our github org where the
code all lives all the fun stuff and
also um our slack workspace which is
where kind of ongoing discussions have
been happening since
since our birds of a feather last year
so i think that is all of the all of the
sort of logistical bits um
again thank you so much for being here
and i'll kick things off by just um
talking a little bit about sort of
context and history to to kind of orient
people um and then um
and we'll kick things off and i'm i'm
actually the the first presenter as well
to keep the logistics smooth so um
yeah so the uh the julia mulsim github
organization was was started a few years
back i think primarily by christophe
ortner who you'll hear from later
as well as antoine levitt
to kind of create some visibility start
to create a little bit of a community
around um you know atomistic systems
computational chemistry molecular
simulation
all of these things in the julia
language um also to have a private
registry for kind of not ready for prime
time codes but that that we still want
to be able to you know easily install
and play with um and again yeah just to
be kind of a hub for collaboration to
sort of bring people together
um i got connected with this via
michael herbst who you'll also hear from
later um
through a collaboration with an rpe
funded project that i'm involved in
after he gave a talk on the dftk code
at juliacon 2020 and then the two of us
actually co-organized the birds of a
feather session that happened at julia
con 2021
which has really been kind of the
jumping off point for things like the
slack workspace and and the website and
and the the community starting to to
grow a little bit more in scope which we
hope that this session today will be
will be a further further beginning
further jumping off point uh for all of
that
um
and uh and the a big a big further
outcome of of all of that work was um
you know part of this birds of a feather
session was was really discussing you
know what does this community need what
can we do um what can we do what can we
bring to things beyond the sorts of
ecosystems that already exist in
languages like python um that really
kind of leverages the power of julia
um and the sort of unique capabilities
and one thing that came out of that that
would be really useful would be
something kind of similar to what
something like the atomic simulation
environment or pymat gen does kind of a
unified representation for atomic
geometries molecular structures all of
these kinds of things that could be
easily
shared and used by different codes and
different systems and so
michael myself joe greener who you'll
also hear from later in the session as
well as gregory starkov
kind of spearheaded the development of
the atom's base interface
and so several of the packages you'll
hear from in the beginning of this mini
symposium session um make use of this
interface um support it um and and
there'll also be uh some cool stuff
during the quick pitches at the end uh
for further projects making use of this
and this i think this is a really really
powerful thing to have this idea of
being able to
uh with a few simple functions kind of
represent
uh atomic geometries in a way that can
make it very easy to kind of translate
to whatever whatever internal
representation a code needs to run
really fast um but have this flexibility
to to translate very easily and so this
has enabled uh things like sort of you
adam io that i believe michael will be
talking about for sort of unified um
file reading and writing
pranay during the quick pitches we'll
talk about the beginnings of a
visualization package which i'm
personally really excited about this was
a big a big thing that i had hoped would
come out of this the ability to
visualize atomic geometry is kind of
agnostic to which which particular code
they came out of and of course it also
has the potential to to enable
interoperability between different codes
so we could imagine someday having for
example a ab initio molecular dynamics
code in julia that perhaps uses dftk to
compute the energies and forces and
mali.jl to actually uh to actually
iterate these simulations and this
should in principle be fairly easy to
put together um because we can we can
sort of these structures can kind of
talk to each other in in very easy ways
which which anyone who's ever tried to
translate between different you know
file formats or or representations
within something like a python system
um can can tell you how how meaningful a
thing that is to have um so
yeah so we we really hope that this will
that this will continue to be a really
exciting jumping off point um
and and just continue to to create this
kind of hub for collaboration so again
if you're not already on
on our slack workspace um take advantage
of the link to join that
the pigeonhole to ask questions um yes
anonymous i see your hello just checking
question thanks for testing that that's
all working um
and uh and and really excited to to uh
kick things off today um and and to and
thank you all for your attention um i'll
i'll say a little bit about kind of the
logistics of the rest of the session so
um we'll have the way it's organized is
we have um a few talks from
projects that that have been using the
the atoms base
interface and in many cases this is from
folks who have contributed to the
development of it so that'll be the
first about hour and a half or so
followed by a few contributed community
talks of packages that will hopefully
someday support adam's base or maybe
maybe i'm behind the times and some of
them already do we'll hear from those
folks later and then at the very end
we'll have kind of a quick pitch session
so this will be a mix of sort of shorter
talks kind of smaller smaller kind of um
package advertisements things like this
as well as
kind of pitches for for community
projects
solicitations for help and development
for ideas for testing all these kinds of
things and that's that's really meant to
hopefully be the sort of sequel to to
what happened with adam's base last year
um so so i definitely i look forward to
that and and hearing some of those some
of those ideas contributed from the
community and and hopefully that
hopefully some of you logged in will
will perhaps become contributors and
collaborators uh on some of those
projects
um
so
that is
actually about all i have in terms of
introductory material it went a little
bit a little bit shorter than i
anticipated but um i suspect we'll have
some really good really good q a
um going on later that will that will
easily take up the rest of that time so
i think what i might do is uh unless any
any questions come through on the pigeon
hole
or comments on anything um in the next
minute or so i might just
continue onward um in in my own
presentation um but again thank you all
thank you all for being here and uh and
very excited very excited to share with
you
all of this exciting stuff so let me get
my screen share going here
okay
having the same problem that kristoff
had before
okay i think that's working now
great
all right someone send me a private chat
if that looks bad but i think as far as
i can tell from the preview we are okay
um
great so um
just gonna just gonna forge ahead here
um so i'm gonna talk so i'm i am uh
another another hat that i wear within
all of this is i'm the lead developer of
the camellia ecosystem um for machine
learning in atomistic systems um and
sort of the core the court of crux of
this ecosystem is chemistry
featurization which i think is a really
really unique among tools out there for
this um and i think will will enable a
lot of really exciting stuff in the
future so
i'm going to focus the talk today on on
the sort of evolution of that uh to give
people some context on on where it's
been and where it is today and
hopefully uh where where it's going
in the future so
i'll present to you a brief history of
chemistry featurization as well as some
lessons that have been learned along the
way
in terms of ways to reach me personally
my personal website and twitter handle
are here and via the website you can
find basically any other way to reach me
that that you might be interested in
um
cool so uh
this all started initially with my
development of atomicgraphnets.jl which
actually happened before chemistry
featurization came along um it was
really set up as sort of a homework
assignment for myself i was i was just
starting to learn julia just starting to
learn how flex.jl worked um and so i
basically just re-implemented a lot of
cgcnn.pi
in julia with a few tweaks um i can i
can go into detail about that um if
people are curious but but i'm not going
to focus on that here um and essentially
out of the box it had competitive
performance in terms of accuracy and
pretty much blue cg cnn.pie out of the
water
in terms of performance which was really
really cool and gratifying because this
was before i'd really learned anything
at all about how to how to optimize
julia code um which is which is a
journey that i'm still on personally
today um so it's very very cool when
something just kind of works out of the
box like that and that definitely this
was a big part of of me catching the
julia bug so to speak
um but uh if the slide advance will work
there we go um so chemistry
featurization was born somewhat after um
atomic graph nets um really out of a out
of my own frustration with the kind of
standard approaches to featurizing uh in
this case atomic graphs but but really
broadly any kind of atomic structure and
these are very sort of opaque and rigid
ways of doing things so i'm going to
pick on cgcnn.pi here a little bit
because this is the one that i'm
familiar with but this but these kinds
of approaches exist everywhere so
basically in cgcnn.pi
um it comes bundled with this
atominit.json which is basically just a
bunch of bit strings
inside a dictionary and so these are
different atomic numbers and there are
these long bit strings that encode if
you dig into the supplementary
information of the original paper
a bunch of different features in sort of
one hot vectors that have been binned in
various ways and that's what these uh
these um
columns are showing and and this was
just very frustrating to me because it's
it's very hard to decode to understand
what information is even there and if
you wanted to tweak this if you wanted
to for example drop off one of these
properties or maybe use a different
number of bins
for one of these continuous valued
properties
this is not at all easy to do you would
have to write code from scratch to
regenerate this atominit.json file
and that just that just seemed really
clunky it seemed like part of the
package should be uh having the ability
to do that in a very flexible way so
this is kind of what motivated the
design principles underlying chemistry
featurization which are first
transparency so rather than just having
this this bit string sitting in a
dictionary in a json file i want it to
be very transparent up front very
obvious very easy to query
what information i'm encoding and and
how is that being encoded with what
fidelity
flexibility i want to be able to change
that i want to be able to include or
exclude different features
change the fidelity with which i encode
them maybe construct those bins for
those continuous valued features in a
logarithmic way or a linear way
depending on the range of values have
all of that kind of flexibility
in a very easy and configurable way
i want it to be invertible so i want to
be able to give in one of these bit
strings kind of invert it and say you
know with what precision have i you know
have i encoded this value precisely as i
might be able to do for a categorical
feature such as you know which column of
the periodic table my element is in uh
or or with what you know how how wide is
the bin if it's if it's a continuous
value feature that i've had to sort of
chop up into bins in some way
versatility i want to be able to use the
same api to featurize different kinds of
atomic systems molecules crystals
interfaces um also different
representations so atomic graphs or
representations that take into account
the entire 3d structure of the system
i want this this api to be flexible to
all of those things so that i don't have
to learn a different approach every time
i want to build a different kind of
model or use a different kind of
representation
um and i want it to be extensible so you
know i've focused so far on graphs
primarily but i want someone else to be
able to i want i want the api to be
flexible enough for someone else to come
along and say i actually want to build
this particular molecular fingerprint
futurizer or whatever um and and
that that to all be able to kind of fit
into this um so the initial concept
behind chemistry featurization was that
it would really be a sort of one-stop
shop kind of including all of these
things
inside it um in in one in one sort of
big package
um
and and this was this was kind of the
initial concept and so here as of as of
july 2020 when we first released the
package um
this is kind of what it looked like so
using
ase.i o so the atomic simulation
environment file reading via pi call we
would read in a structure file which
could be anything that ase could read um
again this started out focused and still
is to some extent in terms of the the
fleshed outness of the implementation
focused on atom graphs so we would build
this atom's object
um there would be some sort of
featurization scheme so perhaps we're
featurizing individual nodes of the
graph or we're using this weave
featurizer which includes features of
pairs
um this would encode the features and
then the output would be this featurized
atoms object so again you're maintaining
your connect connected to this atom's
object is all of the inform not only the
features that we've encoded but also the
information about how we encoded them
that enables that that invertibility and
that transparency and that would go out
and be
um
be the input to some uh to some machine
learning model
um
and and this this you know worked
reasonably well at the start um
around the end of 2020 i was fortunate
to to receive a fellowship from the
molecular sciences software institute or
mulcy um that gave me support to work on
uh this project pretty much exclusively
for about six months so that was very
exciting and that helped to push things
forward and i also um through
the julia summer of code through google
connection with google summer of code um
had uh oops
um
anantasa madam um come on online for the
project um and he was a really a really
tremendous force in in kind of ideation
and and helping to push things forward
and and
um
and and especially in chemistry
featurization but also in some of the
other pieces that he worked on um was
just was was really really instrumental
in in where the code went over the
ensuing honest a year or so he worked
over the summer he's continued to help
um in in maintaining things and um
around uh shortly through this part
partly through this time um
we kind of branded this as the camellia
ecosystem so this includes
um chemistry featurization atomic graph
nets and and other things that are that
are still being developed so it's this
is meant to be the hopefully julia
ecosystem for machine learning with
atoms
um and again kind of chemistry
featurization is the gateway here and
then that would create these inputs to
these other models such as atomic graph
nets
um along the way as we as we worked on
building out this this uh functionality
within chemistry futurization
uh to support you know other kinds of
features um and all of these kinds of
things um chemistry featurization uh
started to get really bloated so you
know you'd fix one thing the ci was
broken you fix one thing and then and
then you try to fix the other things and
that breaks the first thing and it was
just you know it was really just kind of
a mess
um
and uh
and
uh sorry just making sure i can see the
see the pigeon hole here um and and we
realized that that having chemistry
featurization by itself be this kind of
one-stop shop um really doesn't make
sense uh it makes the package
tremendously difficult to maintain
especially with all of the the python
dependencies and other things um
and uh and so this caused us to kind of
rethink how it was structured and moved
to a much more
honestly kind of more julian like small
small nimble package um and this was
also inspired by you know around during
this whole time um having been working
on the adam's base package and learning
a lot more about about the power of
interfaces in julia and this this whole
uh you know paradigm um and realizing
that really chemistry featurization
makes a lot more sense as an interface
than as a package that has too many
concrete implementations in it so here's
just a snapshot from the project.tommel
where we cut out a lot of implement a
lot of specific implementations um
notably pai call is gone which was which
is very very nice for the ci to pass
much more frequently
and so so what does this package look
like today um today it is mostly a very
lightweight interface that has a few
concrete functionalities um exported in
it um it does support featurization of
atoms-based syst atoms-based systems um
of course and uh and we we critically
have this kind of separation of concerns
and i think this is this is also
uh somewhat unique um compared to a lot
of other systems that are out there for
this kind of thing so we have the notion
of a feature descriptor so this would be
something like um
you know i want to encode the atomic
mass of an element or i want to encode
which block of the periodic table that
element sits in s p d f etc um that's
that's the idea of a feature descriptor
so those two that i mentioned would be
what we call element feature descriptors
where you can essentially get them from
a lookup table on a single element you
could have atom feature descriptors that
are still a feature of a single atom but
may depend on the environment so perhaps
the
oxidation state would be an example of
that
um as well as of course pair features
bond features um and potentially even
environment features that capture kind
of larger scale
uh larger scale features so that's
that's a feature descriptor then we have
a codec so this is the thing that
actually does the encoding so this could
be a one hot encoder like i described
for the the
graph featurization where either if it's
a categorical feature then you just you
just make this one hot vector if it's a
continuous valued feature like the
atomic mass then you sort of make some
choices about deciding about bit
creating it uh creating bins um and
build a one hot vector that way but you
could also imagine other ways to do this
you could encode the value directly and
maybe that's you know with just some
perhaps normalization or scaling
and that might be useful for certain
applications so in the next kind of so
those two um are at the level of
individual features and we have a
featurization scheme so that's
essentially some collection of features
and how
excuse me
and how you're going to combine those
together
um
excuse me to actually
feed into some
sorry about that
um feed into some model so you know
maybe you create these
these one-hot vectors
and those get stacked together into a
matrix and that's the actual data
representation that is
that is then fed into a model and then
we have the featurized structure so
that's um
the thing that i showed before so you
have
both the representation of the structure
so for a graph that would be like the
adjacency matrix or maybe it's a full
list of coordinates if you're
representing the full structure um along
with the associated set of features
again kind of
cooked up and and structured in the way
that they're designed to be feed fed
straight into the model
so
what's next um i have to confess there
has not been a substantial development
between that uh february of this year
and today um a lot of my effort has been
focused on on a few other things a
quick plug for my electrochemical
kinetics dot jl talk later this week um
but in the new position that i'm
starting in the fall as i mentioned i'll
be taking on students and i'm hoping to
have a few students um coming back to
doing more active development um on this
package
um and and i'm excited for that and of
course always welcome uh contributions i
think um
there's there's a balance to be struck
here between you know having this be
really full featured having all the
different featurizers that one might
expect
um uh implemented um and also thinking
about you know what can what can julia
bring uniquely to this um so that we're
not just kind of duplicating something
that that for example already exists in
in a package like deep chem or or uh one
of these others
uh that are out there so so there's kind
of a balance there but but we're always
open to contributions um especially if
you know um
if anyone uh
uh yeah if you're interested in using
something or building something or
improving our documentation or anything
i'm very very open to to all of that
so
that's all very much encouraged um to
wrap up i'll talk about a few a few
lessons learned and are reinfersed many
of these uh may be maybe quite familiar
to folks um julia interfaces are awesome
this whole paradigm i think you know
between adam's base and this this kind
of redevelopment effort on chemistry
featurization it's really
been emphasized to me how powerful this
whole idea is
um
i think this this slack message from a
month this is quite a bit longer than
seven days ago now
um uh really really kind of takes it
home you know we wanted to be the
interface package uh and then and then
realize that we are the interface
package um
and that's really kind of the way
forward um really really kind of sums up
this realization that we had
um
be willing to think big but unashamed to
start small so as i mentioned i'm hoping
that camellia can become
a really big
and powerful and full-featured system
but you have to start somewhere so right
now we're focused on these graphs
and then um and featurizing those and
doing a really good job there
and we're hoping that
that will have some great contributions
from other folks and and some students
continuing to to build all of this out
and then finally uh
sometimes writing up the description of
your problem to send to the julius slack
is enough to you for you to solve the
problem
rubber duck debugging rubber duck coding
uh but when it's not they'll probably
still answer your question within
minutes um and that's just a testament
so i think the julia community broadly
that's not really specific to the julius
slack or the julia molson slack or the
julia discord
it's just a really great and helpful
community and around and people are are
so excited to
to
contribute and and help out and and
that's just been tremendous so
i'm really really grateful for all of
that
um
finally acknowledgments um thanks to um
arpa-e as well as uh the molsi uh for
funding and also to my mulcy mentors cnn
sam
who really helped me get up to speed
with a lot of the sort of software
development nuts and bolts in terms of
getting ci working getting the docs page
hosted all of these things that i was
somewhat new to um
i feel like i i have a much stronger
grounding in uh thanks to a lot of their
help and advice
of course to do google summer of code uh
for their funding of anant who's who's i
really can't overstate how how
transformative and helpful he's been um
on a lot of different fronts of this
project um daria my uh my friend and
adjoint wizard uh a lot of the the
actual training of some of these models
um would not
would not be working uh were it not for
his help um to
uh the ever the extremely talented
carmelian for the beautiful camellia
logo that we have
um and also to my postdoc advisor bencat
uh for for supporting all of this and
and letting me kind of go off on on some
of these these crazy journeys um that
were not always obviously relevant to
what i was being funded by uh at first
um
so uh that's all i have uh seems like
i'm more or less right on time now um
thank you all for the attention and uh
hopefully uh maybe some questions will
start coming in so far i just see
i think the the oh we have one new
question coming in okay
um what are some examples of ml models
with atoms as input features whether in
research or industry use um
okay yeah great question so um so one
example is uh as i sort of alluded to um
is graph convolutional neural nets so so
i'll pull up my little slide that has
kind of an explainer on that um
oops i lost the pigeon hole there it is
um
so so this is an example here where you
would have for example the uh some some
atomic structure
so i guess i should i should clarify
quickly that that it's
it's atomic features but they're
features of some overall structure so we
would build
build some sort of maybe i'll go back
momentarily we you know suppose you have
some cartoon structure like this um you
can represent this as a so you can think
of this as a ball and stick model like
in a chemistry class um and but we can
represent this as a graph so the the
balls here then become nodes and the the
sticks so to speak are edges and that
graph
can be an adjacency matrix so this is
this is a unweighted graph in our case
we actually typically use weighted
graphs where these would be
some continuous value between zero and
one
to account for features like how far
away the atoms are from each other and
then we can featurize these um so if you
imagine
the simplest sort of feature would be
just a single number on each one um so
we can build the laplacian matrix i
won't go into all of what all that is um
but um
this idea that graph convolutional graph
convolution kind of serves as it's
diffusional it's it's a it's an
operation that respects the structure of
the graph and and kind of allows
information to diffuse respecting this
connectivity here and so in this cartoon
example i show um there's uh just a
single number is the feature for each
node but if you imagine expanding this
out into a matrix where you have a
vector as a feature for each node um
that's what typically happens in these
in these models
and so in this case those vectors that i
was talking about before um so you might
encode in something like a bit string um
different features or
sets of features
and then feed it into a model like this
and so you in a in a graph convolutional
neural net you would typically have a
few of these convolutional layers and
then there's some kind of pooling
operation to get to a consistent length
feature vector and then some uh feed
forward just typical densely connected
layers out to
um one or perhaps several outputs
depending on if you're if you're doing a
kind of regression or a classification
problem um
so uh hopefully that addresses addresses
that question that's that's one example
um that's
uh
an example that i've been i've been
working with pretty extensively but
there are other examples out there as
well
one area that i'm i'm really excited
about and hope to hope to get started
working in is
some of these equivariant models where
you actually represent the full
structure
excuse me and you can build a model that
respects
not only the connectivity
of the structure the way that the way
that a gcn does but also
aspects so for example if you if you
represent the 3d structure in some set
of coordinates if you just rotate that
coordinate system in an equivalent model
you can guarantee that the output if the
output is some sort of vectorial or
tensorial quantity it will rotate
appropriately or the invariant to that
kind of rotation
um while still retaining more structural
information than than
the sort of flattening into a graph
necessarily does and that's another kind
of model where you would have features
of individual atoms
as input to that um
so hopefully that addresses your
question sundar thanks thanks for asking
it um
and uh we've got another minute or so if
um
if anyone um
has any other questions they want to
pop in um let's see i think that
okay i don't see anything else on the
pigeon hole
uh oh there's a couple more that popped
in here okay um can you represent
chirality that's so yeah in a graph in a
typical graph model no you cannot um
that that is definitely a big
shortcoming there's actually a lot of
interesting papers um feel free to slack
me and i can point you to some of them
talking about the shortcomings of
different kinds of representations and
what sorts of features you can or cannot
capture um
so that that's a big one in a
traditional graph model you can't there
are some uh newer kind of emerging
approaches uh where you can capture uh
capture features like that and that's i
think a really interesting area
um
has there been papers using this package
um so there are not any published papers
yet um
uh that is something that will will
hopefully change in the relatively near
future um
uh
yeah that's that's kind of the short
answer there um documentation and
tutorials yes thank you um if you go to
camellia.org
that's the quickest and most and easiest
to remember um url for that and and that
will link to the camellia has its own
github organization um which should link
you to all of the documentation for all
of this stuff and and please please
please if you find something out of date
or incorrect in the documentation do not
hesitate to file an issue i want all of
that to be to be up to date and helpful
for people and and we've got some good
stuff up there now with sort of pluto
notebooks to step through things and and
a lot of different examples um so that
is pretty much my time so i am going to
uh stop sharing my screen
and um
turn things over here to joe let me
add him and
his slides to the stream
hang on sorry i am all over the place
here okay beautiful um
all right i think i think you are live
joe and uh and take it away
great thanks a lot rachel and um
just like to say you know this is a
great idea to have this you know
symposium bringing together the
community we've seen so much development
in um you know just one year so
let's try and do this regularly and keep
building this community um
so i'm going to speak to you about poly
which is
a molecular simulation package in julia
and i started it about uh maybe two
two a bit years ago um three years ago
or something just as a way to kind of
learn basically um
to learn julia and
and to learn molecular dynamics and
since i moved to the lmb in cambridge
i now get to work on this
or do research with this package full
time so it's seen a lot of development
on my side and it's also seen a lot of
development from a number of other
people
which is fantastic
so
uh i suspect most of you heard of
molecular dynamics given the topic of
talk but basically you set up a physical
system
with coordinates and velocities and you
define the rules that determine the
forces in the system
and then you kind of should press press
play and you let the system run
i know the julian community has a lot of
differential equations people in it so
from that perspective
you're basically just numerically
integrating the second order
differential equation defined by f
equals ma
and this is often very computationally
expensive um there's not really any
shortcuts um
if you want to study for instance
protein protein binding which might take
milliseconds or even seconds
you might be limited to a fentanyl
second time step which means that you
need to estimate a billion
10 million steps
to see what you want to see which
uh which which does take a long time
but md has been very successful i
thought it's been around for probably
uh
half a century now only 50 years or so
and it has helped us to understand
processes in in chemistry and biology as
well as further
and it's gonna it's gonna be here for
you know the foreseeable future and i
think it's gonna become even more
important because
uh computer resources just keep getting
better
particularly the gpu space we've seen
loads of innovative machine learning
approaches
and for those familiar with kind of our
fold in the protein structure evolution
we're getting more and more starting
structures
how do you do molecular simulation well
there's a number of
you know brilliant packages um
which have been around for many years
and have have big uh used communities
and most most of them kind of fall into
the same
the same idea where you have fast
kernels under the hood uh to run
simulations for instance you might have
a c plus plus kernel for the cpu
and you might have a cuda kernel for
cuda enabled devices
and then they have some layer on top
that the user interacts with
so that could be a
binary in the case of gromacs or you
could have a python interface like open
command
and they often have kind of
configuration files where you declare
your your system parameters
um
i think it's fair to say most of these
packages are hard to interact with all
the way down by which i mean right from
the top level of user interface all the
way down to the metal
and if you want to customize them you
often have to
[Music]
you know
kind of
jump into the package at certain points
using a certain
language which
isn't isn't offered the best way to
develop new simulations
and then as we look to um you know
last 10 years neural networks have
become predominant
and people are now starting to integrate
those into molecular dynamics and none
of these packages has
um you know support for natively
different simulations
so what is monique well it's pure duty
implementation of molecular dynamics
it's one language all the way down
100 julia
and
simulation scripts are
just junior scripts
so in terms of design philosophy it's
kind of
become fairly recently it's become
closest to openmm
which is it which is in python
but has multiple kernels under the hood
and a key philosophy of the package is
that when a user defines potentials or
simulators they should be just as easy
to define and as fast as the features
built in
everything's defined imperatively in
julio so there's no kind of
you know custom script like custom
declarative languages if you want to
write a simulator you just write a
junior function
it's differentiable with zygotes
most of the packages is differentiable
and
it's kind of under very accurate
development it's not it's not stable or
fully covered by tests but it
has seen a lot of development
particularly the last few months
so what can it do um well you have the
kind of classic non-bonded interactions
lenny jones coulomb gravity sofia mia
and the bonded interactions so harmonic
bonds angles more spawns cosine angles
torsions and position restraints so the
combination of those first two points
lets you simulate
biomolecules and
[Music]
know gases and
uh quite polymers quite a few other
systems
uh you can read in open them and grow
maxwell's field files and
uh you can read in coordinates using
chemfels.jl which gives you access to a
lot of different file formats
uh rachel's already introduced the asmr
base interface um so it's
it implements that interface so anything
that's compatible with that will also be
compatible with the system type and
volley
there's a few different simulators um
all the kind of
you know standard ones in in in wide use
today um
for non-enhanced uh simulation so verlay
velocity valet
and a very flexible logical integrator
thanks to noevlassel
and
energy minimization a series of
thermostats
and
[Music]
periodic boundary conditions in a cubic
box with optional infinite boundaries
and the list goes on so
if you want to track properties
throughout the simulation you can use
the logger interface
and
cut off algorithms
for defining what happens
a long range for non-bonded interactions
uh we use various we have various
nameless implementations to speed up the
calculations not bonded forces including
um
including link with with cell list map
and uh we've implemented implicit
solvent generalized bore methods
uh it's uniform compatible all the way
down which well pretty much all the way
down so what that means is um
physical quantities uh if you want to
they can have
units you can either run the whole
system without units in which case it's
a bit wild west you have to trust that
you know what you're doing or you can
run with units which is the the
recommended way and it's slightly slower
and every that means every physical
property in the system has a unit
and if you try and add you know a
nanometer to a picosecond it will throw
an error and that's you know initially
that seems a bit annoying but actually
it's really really useful
and it's done
wonders for debugging really
and it's got some analysis functions but
this judy is a lovely language so you
can just write your own of course
um
it's got
basic visualization which i'll show
later with geomecia
automatic multi-threading
and then some has
some gpu acceleration which i'll
describe as well
and what it doesn't have at the minute
uh is
in heart sampling and
although that's coming soon
as i'll describe
uh it doesn't have constrained bonds
um
it doesn't have
non-cubic boundaries um
this is this is coming soon i know this
was a highly requested feature and i'm
working on it right now
um
particle mesh your summation which is
uh takes a kind of a reasonable fraction
of time of standard biome electrical
simulations it doesn't have that
hopefully it will wonder
pressure coupling
um kind of system preparation um
when you want to run large you know very
very very large systems you generally
kind of decompose the
space into different domains and then
solve them independently
and we don't have that yet but it'll be
nice too
uh
free energy calculations for drug
discovery we don't have
uh the api is still a bit um
a bit flexible it's still changing to
find the right the right approach
coverage is going up all the time we do
have a
number of quite stringent tests but not
everything is tested
and performance is currently
not as good as competing software
okay so on the subject for testing i
mean when you're developing an md
package you really have to be um
you know
pay even more attention to testing than
usual because it's so easy to get out
something which looks
like a real simulation but it's just
not what you thought it was
so currently we can simulate standard
proteins with the the forces the
energies and the trajectories matching
open mm which in turn matches uh amber
and the gradient zygote max finite
differencing um for reversing the
forward mode ad
and so at least for kind of simulation
of standard what you might call standard
proteins without anything funky going on
um
it is it is well tested
uh i guess the big the big kicker the
crux is that code runs much slower than
widely used md software
for two reasons
uh first the technical requirements of
differentiability
uh which we're not compromising on and
and also just the heavy optimization of
existing software over um
over many decades
so in particular uh the gpu path
uh the minutes broadcast over the whole
neighbor list in order to work with the
zygote broadcasting
and to get around the fact that as i got
a dozen of mutation and so this
leads to very very poor memory usage and
gpu saturation
so the next kind of major development in
the package
which i hope to look at in the next few
months is
to write gpu channels for the for
summation
and to integrate those with enzyme.jl
which
is able to differentiate through
gpu kernels
okay so that's long enough without some
code so let's have a look at the
simulation you can define the components
individually and run so this uses the
latest release which came out yesterday
so you
set up your your boundary conditions
uh set up some some kind of constants
and then
you define your set of atoms um the
player's atoms function just
places some atoms in space without
clashing uh you give them some
velocities according to the maximal
multiple distribution at a given
temperature
we're going to run with leonard jones
parameters which is just a simple
attractive repulsive potential
we're going to use this
fairly standard velocity verlet
integrator
with a two frames per second time step
and uh the anderson thermostat which
just randomly bumps particles to keep at
a certain temperature
and then we set on this system struct
and call
the simulate function and that kind of
approaches cooling system and then
simulate is kind of the way the package
works throughout
and then we can go visualize um so this
is exported by
this is available in the package which
gives you a quick uh geomecia
video of what's going on
and that simulation you saw earlier that
that's the script on the left so you can
set to also set up simulations in an
analogous way to open them
um
but it all runs in one language and
so in this case we
read a force field from the xml files
and then we read the system from a pdb
file and that force field
and in this case we want to look at
energies and we want to
write out
a structure so write out the trajectory
and then it's standard approach to
minimize
and in this case we don't do
equilibration you could do that with
restraints but in this case we just give
the system random velocities
and then use a launch of an integrator
and simulate it on multiple threads
and then it's shown in python on the
right
okay so a bit of a gallery just some
kind of quick grab bag of simulations
so
peptide you saw in the first
slide that was simulated with
with molly uh some like diatomic gas
uh
you know i said it was compatible with
uniform one of the nice things about
that is that you don't you can use any
unit system you want so
if you want to simulate the solar system
as shown here that's you know maybe 15
orders of magnitude bigger than an atom
but
not a problem you can still do that
uh and plot it
and
you can trade as i'll just discuss in a
minute you can train differential
simulations to reproduce a familiar logo
um
you can make a break bonds throughout
the simulation and of course you can
just use the package for you know you
have to see that you can use edit
plotting energies and the like as well
okay so i'll briefly describe
differentiable simulation this is the
major research direction of the packages
my own research for those who are
familiar with recurring neural networks
the idea is you process a series of
inputs
via hidden states
and then
using your network and you get some
output you then compare to true outputs
you obtain some loss function and then
because you've implemented this in an
automatic differentiation framework you
just press uh dot backward and it will
give you the loft the the gradient about
loss with respect to all the parameters
in your network and you can improve the
network
so differential simulation is analogous
except um instead of inputs you have
starting coordinates and then instead of
hidden states you have the trajectories
that's the
velocities and then at the end you can
generate whatever loss function you want
so for instance you could compare the
final coordinates to the native
coordinates of a protein and get an rmsd
loss and because you've implemented
automatic differentiation framework
you click the backward and you obtain
the gradient of that loss with respect
to your forceful parameters so it lets
you answer the question how do i improve
the force field to reduce some loss
so you can imagine learning to stabilize
a native structure
at epoch zero your potentials could be
flat and then as epox training go on you
eventually learn to counter the starting
velocities
and if you want to see this approach
used to learn of course grain of
force field of proteins you can read
that paper there
so does this software exist well some
packages in the last two years have come
out for this uh probably most most
noticeably jax md and jacks
um but that doesn't have protein support
as of yet torch md which is does have
protein support but is perhaps
fundamentally limited by um by its by
torch implementation and in the wider
ecosystem there are other differential
physics packages as well
so molly can do differential simulations
and that was a kind of key key key
approach when developing it so to just
give you some quick numbers um
speed if you want to run say 3 000 atoms
is in a small peptide
and you can
you can run a million steps which is
about a nanosecond
and that would take take 100 hours but
if you wanted to write it with implicit
solvent uh you could run a 15 residue
protein
in 14 hours or so for a million steps
that's equivalent to a million step
neural network um and just to give you
the ideas of some lost values on the
right
uh if you take the loss starting
structure then this tells you that
as you increase this parameter this is
the sigma value of nitrogen your rmsd
goes up
and as you
increase the hydrogen mass that the rmsd
goes up so you can see how you could use
these gradients to um to improve
your force field
for those wondering about how this
affects gradient explosion uh if you use
a larger integrator it really actually
really helps to prevent great exploding
and so currently it's achievable to
improve all that implicit solar models
and so that's what we're doing
so ongoing work uh contribution is very
welcome uh we're on the julian morrison
slack there's a channel there hashtag
molly
um
so so jdev who's a gsoc student um he's
making great progress on retro exchange
there's a pull request for that you can
check out
uh prior is a jsoc student is is doing
well on constraint algorithms
um
and the james schloss and the sessmitz
project mit are kind of
taking a look at this enzyme compatible
gpu kernels which i think are the major
development of the package going forward
hopefully i'll get a chance to work on
that as well
um i'm looking at differentiable
simulations uh the apis is going to
continue to change sorry about that um
we're breaking things in order to find
the right way to do it
but at some point there'll be a stable
interface and there'll be a software
paper
so thanks a lot to the contributors an
incomplete list of whom are listed here
no he was just here recently and had a
very productive week adding adding a lot
of features
um thanks to all the julia contributors
and package authors particularly i have
to mention zygote kudos statically ken
files train rules atoms basic unit 4
which are all fantastic
uh the julian julia mull sim community's
opening of gromacs which are just really
nice and i placed a lot of the design
off and then kind of my own academic
acknowledgements and stuart's cheers
group of the nfb and david jones group
at ucl where a lot of this work was done
so thank you very much i have your
attention
great thanks a lot joe for that awesome
whirlwind tour of the continued progress
with molly
we have a question from kristoff um
the issue with non-cubic pbc this should
only be a neighborless issue and i
thought both neighborlists and solas
maps support that what is missing
um yeah i mean yeah it's it's coming in
very soon it it's it's it's not just the
nameless issue unless unless you also
store the um the vectors with
the displacement vectors with the
labelist as it is in molly you you
calculate the naples and
every step you recalculate the
displacements
and that opens up algorithms like
calculation they list every 10 steps or
so
so we just need the algorithms to
calculate the um
the distances in the triclinic blocks
but i mean that's actually
it's on a branch now it just needs it
just needs testing basically but it's
gonna come in hopefully hopefully the
next two weeks it should be there
very cool uh we also have a question on
youtube from barrel r what method is
used to compute the potential energy is
it ab initio if yes is it implemented
100 in julia no c plus plus or fortran
call or any other libraries
yeah so the main focus of the package on
the minute is biomolecular simulation so
it's classical um
classical electric mechanics force
fields um so just harmonic bonds angles
leonard jones um
periodic torsions and coulomb um but you
can you can define your own interactions
uh i i personally haven't defined
anything quantum dft or avenue ever
but i know some people are interested in
doing that so perhaps perhaps that will
be in the package one day and if you
want kind of more density functional
stuff or have an issue of stuff probably
check out dftk
which is a fantastic segue to the next
talk i see one more question here let's
see
um
okay we have one more question from
kristoff and then we'll transition over
to michael
suppose the cost of the force field is
order 100 microseconds to one
millisecond per atom mlips would the
overhead of the force field then be
sufficient to make molly comparable with
lamps
um
[Music]
i don't know i'd have to i'd have to
i'd have to run the numbers i think that
the main barrier to lamps uh
to being comparable with lamps is that
uh we don't really do anything smart
about
you know multi
we multi-threading um in terms of doing
domain knee composition or anything like
that so as soon as you go above a few
thousand atoms um
we don't make particularly good use of
uh
yeah we don't we don't do the right
thing algorithmically i think so i think
there's a way to go uh
before that but
there's nothing fundamentally stopping
it's just a case of somebody
somebody doing i think
great
thanks a lot if anyone has
further further follow-up questions or
just generally wants to stay engaged
with the community i'll briefly pin the
link to join our slack channel um and as
joe mentioned there's a there's a molly
channel over there
but to
stay mostly on time i'm gonna hand it
over to michael
who's gonna talk about dftk so it was a
great segue there um take it away
michael
yeah thank you very much rachel um
thanks everyone for tuning in so indeed
my job is now to move to exactly what
has been asked in the in the recent
question that the the question of
basically generating data uh using
electronic structure theory using up
initial methods and in particular i will
be talking about the density functional
toolkit dftk a package we developed over
the past few years for density
functional theory simulations and as you
can see here from my affiliation i'm
actually not a simulation person
primarily i'm affiliated with the
mathematics department so my primary
focus is certainly on doing simulations
but more
but actually also understanding really
the mathematics behind these simulations
and for example in collaboration with
people from multiple communities work on
improving algorithms for density
function theory like one thing we did
here really i'm going to go into a bit
of details later basically improving
dft computations for mixed systems for
systems composed of metals and
insulators
we did some work on error control of dft
basically being able to get numerical
arrow bounds for band structures
i'm not going to talk about the details
here but feel free to ask if you're
interested and actually the main focus
of my talk is really to give you some
idea how the density functional toolkit
how dftk really is intended to bridge
between communities to for example
enable questions on numerical analysis
enable some work on high performance
computing but at the same time really
have a code that is useful for
simulations useful to develop new models
now
what i want to talk about today is
really give you some overview of why
this whole project the fdk was started
and as you might know density functional
theory is a very prominent method in up
initial simulations and electronic
structure theory and there are already
tens of packages so you might answer you
might ask the question of like why do we
even bother then i'll give you a brief
look at some recent features we got
since my julia con talk two years ago
basically some things we did and what we
are planning to do in the future
but before i go into the details let me
maybe give you first a little bit of a
motivation for doing dft calculations
and in particular for looking at dft
calculations from a mathematical point
of view because as you might know dft
has been around for many years so the
question is maybe like why why bother
why bother now and the the changing um
the changing aspect in my opinion is
that over the past let's say 10 years 20
years what has become very prominent is
an aspect known as computational
materials design the idea here is for
example let's say we want to develop a
new catalyst for an electrochemical
reaction something that is indeed
happening in the
asset differentiate project that rachel
was mentioning where i also take part
and basically what what is happening
there is that
they are basically from a very simple
setup already um having let's say um
transition metal hose material which is
doped with a single transition metal
atom on top right so something
comparatively simple as a structural
setup one really wants to now understand
systematically which combination of
transition metal hose plus transition
method opened is useful to get a new um
and yeah a very efficient catalyst and
already this very simple design space
here doing a very quick back of the
envelope uh setup you get to something
like a few hundred thousand
per million of cities to really
systematically understand this design
space and find
uh
do you hear me guys
was i just briefly disconnected
it was skipping for a moment it seems
like it's fine now oh great where did
you guys lose me
just that i know where to pick up
um i think you
uh it was it was maybe like the the
previous 20 seconds or so okay all right
so basically the point is that having
these millions of possibilities clearly
um experimental yeah just a pure
experimental route is not sufficient to
to uh yeah
to enable this and to understand really
systematically over this large design
space what's going on so this is really
the regime
of computational materials design of
really doing
systematic dft computations for example
and really i should say that this has
been a remarkable success over the past
years with exponential growth in papers
and databases that are dealing with
these sort of methods and i think it's
pretty clear that this is going to be a
crucial tool to tackle 21st century
challenges now where does dft come in
and where does the need for mathematical
investigations come in well if you're
doing these screening studies there's
really a lot of parameters you choose
like basically first of all you
typically do a whole hierarchy of dft
simulations as i'm showing here with
slightly different method each time
you're like discarding parts of the
design space and basically at each of
these levels you have a rather compu
complicated computational workflow what
i'm showing here on the right and at the
workflow when you're making let's say
screening decisions at each of the
decisions you're changing parameters you
are you're asking the question like
certain you're asking questions with
respect to certain tolerances and so on
and that throws the question into the
air like what parameters should i choose
what tolerances should i choose and um
people have really come up with quite
elaborate heuristics to do that such
that nowadays something like one percent
of the calculations fail but this is
still thousands of failing calculations
and this is really where our
mathematical work aims to come in really
to bring forward self-adapting so from a
mathematical point of view rigorous dft
algorithms that are black box and that
therefore basically automatically
adapt to the systems that you are
studying without any user intervention
and therefore help to really do these
high throughput computations
in a more reliable way
now of course these questions uh concern
multiple communities basically it's a
question of modeling is the question of
physics it's a question of mathematics
to understand the algorithms high
performance computing to make
calculations fast and i mean overall
these different communities have rather
different demands so mathematicians
often look at let's say reduce toy
models some maybe unphysical cases but
which are interesting to get
understanding to understand how to
improve algorithms for example
scientists really work more on the ideal
idea of the models they don't care so
much about the numerics and of course
practical people who really want to do
the computations and this is really the
crooks with the existing codes i mean to
satisfy these these four these four
different communities with different
demands is quite a difficult uh problem
because by itself the codes are rather
complex for example many features are
implemented many methods and as a result
of this you often have let's say 1
million lines of code and beyond and
overall it's therefore not so easy to
really for example go into deep
algorithmic details and start tinkering
like something what a mathematician
would like to do and moreover because
codes are written in multiple languages
often like a python interface to drive
the computation let's say in the c plus
plus fortune they are to overall um
yeah to overall really make the
computations fast it's not so easy to to
get in and modify some details without
really understanding multiple layers of
the program and multiple uh yeah
multiple languages and this is where the
density function toolkit is really come
in so our our goal here is to stay
within julia for pretty much everything
we have some c dependencies but this is
in fact also optional you could really
do everything in julia now
basically we need to connect to
different communities which means in
this particular case you can do really
simple model problems 1d
arbitrage potentials analytic potentials
you can really understand everything
from a mathematical point of view at
that level develop new algorithms and
without switching to a new code really
apply this now to like meta gga
response calculations so
state-of-the-art problems and um yeah
basically you don't have to rewrite the
code you start with a small thing exp
thing and this really allows us to make
progress with some of the algorithms i'm
going to discuss in just a second it's
really a high productivity research
framework i should say this it's just
basically within the julia ecosystem a
number of standard features are now
available and with 7 000 lines of code
for dft code this is really rather small
and as i said it's just julia and so for
example what i show also later the
initial support for algorithmic
differentiation which we have now
obtained in the code has in fact been
realized in 10 weeks by a gsoc student
and i don't think this would have been
possible in in one of the big codes just
because of the massive number of codes
that people have to really go through
and understand to make progress as
newcomers i should really say
okay so now let me just discuss a few of
the features we have recently obtained
so
i've been mentioning this quest to go
towards black box algorithms so one of
the things we have done is something
known as adaptive damping so if you're
basically zooming in onto the dft
problem in the end what you're going to
solve is a so-called fixed point problem
so you have something known as the
self-consistent field the scf which is
sort of driving yourself forward through
the dft solution and a frequent problem
in these scf algorithms is basically the
so-called damping the stamping factor
alpha as well as the pre-conditioning
this p to the minus one the details
don't matter so much for this talk the
point is that these are parameters which
govern how the scf converges and is
something you have to choose in
traditional codes a priori to get going
and and a big difficulty is that
basically which values you should choose
there depends on the system that you're
modeling and
instead of the art codes it's a bit of a
guessing and trial and error approach to
really move forward on on on these um
yeah on on these parameters until you
have finds found something that actually
works and so the dftk approach here is
for example with respect to the stamping
to use mathematical insight to come
forward with an automatic selection of
the stamping and basically the point i
want to show here is that on two
representative system you see that this
blue adaptive damping basically does
more or less the same as fixed damping
so places where you really choose this a
priori so the key point here is to use
again mathematical insight from toy
problems to figure out this adaptive
algorithm that in the end really does is
almost as good as the fix the standard
traditional approaches but really
without having any parameter to ask from
the user and a similar thing we have
also achieved with respect to this p to
the minus one the so-called
pre-conditioning again here the
difficulty is that basically which
pre-conditioning you should choose
depends on the system under study so in
particular depends whether you have a
metal whether you have an insulator
in your in your as your system and then
if you have mixture you you sort of ask
the question what should you do and in
fact this is a long-standing problem
it's generally not clear what to do for
mixed systems with metals and insulators
and again here we have brought forward
from mathematical analysis on toy
systems um
the so-called erdos mixing approach
which really sort of locally looks at
the system and figures out which part of
the system is a metal which part is an
insulator to really automatically and
without user intervention do the right
thing and again i show some plots here
um really showing that compared to
alternatives it's really doing a great
job i would say
now the last thing i want to briefly
pitch here is
the support for algorithmic
differentiation and in particular
an aspect which is enabled by this is to
understand what is really the dependence
of a property that you simulate with
your density functional theory code on
your choice of the density function
theory model itself
so let's consider for example the case
where we want to optimize the structural
parameters of the system that we are
studying so for example the so-called
lattice constant what you're doing there
is you're really minimizing the energy
that comes out of such a dft computation
with respect to these lattice constants
and now you're asking the question how
sensitive is such an optimal lattice
constant with respect to the dft model
with respect to some parameters that sit
inside the definition of my dft
functional essentially so what we need
is we need such gradients and i mean
doing this in practice
is actually not so simple because what
we have at the dft level is really
multiple layer of iterative methods um
again i haven't really showed this in
this talk but just believe me that
there's really an iterative eigensolver
the scf is iterative then the lattice
optimization this case is also iterative
and moreover we need rather unusual
second order derivatives to compute
these guys over here and basically like
for every quantity of interest if you're
not interested in this lattice constant
but in something else or for every
dft model that you might consider which
changes the definition of this epsilon
here you really need to do something new
so it's sort of a bit of a combinatorial
explosion and the traditional approach
to have one phd student to implement one
such derivative is not so scalable to
this level so what we wanted to really
do is we wanted to use algorithmic
differentiation to break this paradigm
of one phd student per derivative to get
a generic framework for ph for dft
derivatives and really to for example
also allow non-experts to just yeah
implement and obtain such gradients
and indeed this isn't exactly what we
have obtained so here i show some pseudo
code to compute the dft energy and to
optimize basically this this function
with respect to the parameters it's it's
really close to what you would actually
do in the fdk not 100 but very close and
now if you want to compute these
gradients as you would expect from
forward diff for example you just have
to add one line of code right and so i
mean in the end it's really sort of
putting it all together from the julia
tools that we have for in this case
forward div from um the
fact that the ftk really allows to be
flo is really floating point agnostic
and allows the dual numbers from forward
div to be pushed through the whole code
and at the same time really now we have
a very generic implementation for the
so-called response properties that are
needed in the back to compute these
gradients and this really works so here
what i'm showing is uh basically the
lattice constant of silicon a very
simple system for a number of dft
functionals the details don't matter so
much apart from the fact that there's
two parameters copper and beta in these
functionals they take slightly different
values and we are asking here the
question of what's the dependency of the
lattice constant on these values and so
really you can get some sensitivity some
understanding of how stable for example
is my prediction from dft with respect
to changing the dft model itself
okay so
the final thing i want to talk about the
recent features that we have brought
forward is basically the integration of
dftk into the ecosystem uh of atom space
um and so here what i just wanted to
briefly show you is um
yeah it's the code example here on the
right so what we recently have been
working on is the so-called atoms io
package a package which really allows
you to automatically
load
basically structure files in a way that
it's compatible with this atom space
definition that rachel's been talking
about so here you really just say i want
to load this file and in the back atoms
io which i have to say is not yet public
i have some students working on this
it's their student project when it's
finished it will become public and in
the back basically this atom cio
features
some selection mechanism to figure out
what it should use to to pass these zip
files it gives you back something which
is directly compatible with atom space
in the ftk i can now attach to the
potentials which i want to use to model
my problem here i can now using the
so-called dft functionals package dft
functionals interface i can define my
custom dft functional in basically four
lines of code just in this case a scaled
lda functional and you see i now just
integrate that directly into the density
function toolkit using telling the
density function toolkit to use this
exchange functional i just defined in a
few lines up there i do the standard
discretization i run my scf and i get my
answer so you see basically now we have
a generic interface for defining new dft
functionals outside of anything
outside of the density function toolkit
um
an easy way to just load in the
structures and attach the pseudo
potentials get the calculation set up
and running and in the end you get the
familiar standard scf and the standard
output here
okay so now just one slide on future
work what we're currently working on
with another google sum of code student
is gpu support where our goal is really
to minimize code duplication something
that that joe has also been mentioning
we're going to target in particular not
only cuda but also amd gpus
that's something that the community and
the broader electronic structure
community has not really done so much to
the best of my knowledge another thing
that we're targeting is adjoint mode
algorithmic differentiation i've only
been showing forward mode edge mode is
really on the way if you're interested
in that gaspar marcus and nicholas will
have a talk on this next week
in the main circle of julia conn at 12
30 utc on wednesday and uh yeah
basically that allows really like going
to larger number of parameters machine
learned exchange correlation functions
is one prospect for example things we
want to explore in the future and that
brings me to my conclusion so dfdk
hopefully demonstrated this really
bringing maths bringing mathematical
research to dft applications we have a
growing user base at the moment we're
really exploring things coming from the
julia ecosystem ad for example gpu
computing
really trying to look at uncertainties
errors in dft in various ways and um
they're using now dfdk really also for
teaching for outreach there's some
workshops coming up in a few weeks on
the fdk
in paris and yeah so really like
basically using the simplicity of julia
to to spread also the word to students
and to people who are new to dft
my acknowledgements people who have
funded me in particular the google
summer of code and and now
achen where i'm currently residing
people from they called upon the theme
basically most of the work has happened
in particular antoine de vit er
guillaume who's working on gpus nicholas
schmitz who is working on ad mostly same
as marcos people from mit and sessmics
i'm also collaborating thanks for all
the input for the ideas and with that i
really look forward to your questions if
you're interested here's some resources
for you my talk at juliacon 2021 at my
workshop and at the upcoming top this
year
thank you and i look forward to your
questions
great thanks so much michael this is all
super exciting um we have one question
on the pigeon hole do you plan to
leverage the existing chemfiles.jl in
adamsio.jl
yeah for me i mean atom's i o sits in a
different pocket right so cam files is
really more for
oh wait do you meet campfires jl
actually we are already using it
i'm not sure i mentioned this properly i
think i didn't because in fact actually
right here we are already using
campfires.jm
so this like zip files by default and
add mio are passed using campfire so yes
we plan to use that and in fact we
already are yes wonderful um
there i don't see anything else on the
pigeon hole um i'll ask one more quick
question and then uh we'll we'll move on
but again uh brief plug for the for the
slack if anyone else wants to continue
staying engaged michael is certainly
active on there um do i correctly infer
that we know that you now have exact
exchange support and can do hybrid
functionals i know that ah that would be
that would be super awesome yeah
unfortunate answers no i mean we don't
it's not like a first working version
would probably take a few days to code
up i would say so we have all the
infrastructure there but it's uh like
the thing with this is to get this
working competitively to existing codes
to get this working like really in a way
that you can actually use it for
non-trivial practical calculations is a
lot of effort because it's really not so
easy but the first working version
should be quick so but just the fact
that you know if we do it we want to do
it properly and we want to like
investigate some ideas mixed precision
and so on so we haven't really started
this project and since it's not really
come up in the research project we
haven't really investigated it got it so
those those you i think you showed some
pbe sensitivities no those cases
indeed yeah
okay these things down there with ppe
got it
cool all right um well again here let me
uh let me pin the
the slack link briefly if anyone wants
to
stay engaged here um yeah please ask
questions i'm very happy to answer any
time also please like interact on github
we are very happy to answer questions uh
on issues or something with respect to
dfdk
very happy for contributions
great all right and let's
bring in emmanuel who's going to talk
about the sessmics project which has
been
briefly alluded to already and i'm
excited to hear a lot more take it away
manuel
hello everyone can you hear me
hello yep yep we hear you great oh okay
sorry
uh my name is manuel and i'm a postdoc
at julia
i'm working on the sessmix project in
this presentation i'm going to talk
about the general goals of this project
and i will focus on an overview of the
software we are currently developing and
integrating
sessmix stands for center for the
exascale simulation of materials in
extreme environments
the general goal is to advance the
state-of-the-art in predictive
simulations by connecting quantum and
molecular
simulations and materials with
state-of-the-art programming languages
compiler technologies and software
performance engineering tools
underpinned by rigorous approaches to
statistical inference and solidity
modification
in particular our motivating problem is
to study ultra high temperature ceramics
in hypersonic flows
it is an interdisciplinary project that
brings together material science physics
mathematics computer science and other
areas
within mit it involves the center for
computational science and engineering
the center uh the computer science
artificial intelligence laboratory and
the statistics and data science center
but we have external collaborators as
well
we are developing an atomistic suite for
ses mix in julia
in general we want to facilitate the
development and accelerate the
simulations in this project
we want to show that it is possible to
address these simulations using a single
high-level programming language without
compromising performance
that is also known as the two language
problem where typically the simulation
is first developed in a high-level
programming language and due to
performance issues is then rewritten
in an hpc language
in doing so we want to expand the
domestic ecosystem julian expand the
users communities also we want to
contribute to another integration of
this ecosystem with state-of-the-art
software
regarding the specific goals we want
flexible or compostable workflows that
allow us to change different software
components as needed and new software
abstractions that simplify the
development we want new interfaces and
software that enables youtube driven
integration we want to use the power of
the latest developments in automatic
differentiation to accelerate the
implementation of uncertainty
quantification methods training force
computations etc
we want to simplify the creation
learning and integration of normal
linear atomic potentials and we want our
software integrated with other important
developments such as lamps and of course
we want to leverage key julia features
this is our currents of our roadmap we
are in the second year of the project as
you can see there are many tools
involved
during this presentation i will talk
about the subset of tools we are
currently implementing and integrating
to generate a basic version of the
workflows
an integrated ecosystem provides more
alternatives to develop a simulation the
management of hardware resources is
needed software libraries containing
parallel code can fail when several of
these libraries are used simultaneously
their routines end up competing for
computing resources and overall
performance degrades
having more alternatives and properly
managing the use of parallel resources
helps to catalyze advances in our areas
of interest
but it is also a challenge software
development is becoming more and more
accessible which increases the number of
tools and overlapping functionality
furthermore horizontal hierarchies and
in large communities
make it difficult to reach consensus
currently integration efforts are being
developed in particular the atomic
simulation environment provides a set of
tools and python modules for setting up
manipulating running visualizing and
analyzing atomistic simulations
although we are building specific
software for ses mix we are looking to
integrate this state-of-the-art with
state-of-the-art tools developed in
julia and other technologies
julia has many things to offer
as we know julie is a high level high
performance dynamic programming language
all this in the two language problem
also means that domain scientists can
have more control over their work since
they don't have to acquire as much
knowledge about hpc and rewrite their
code
julie is committed to abstract
performance management as much as
possible
working in a single language reduces
duplication of efforts and gives experts
more time to work on their research
in addition the optimizable code is easy
to read which also encourages
collaboration and facilitates
integration
using software composability through
multiple dispatch can facilitate and
therefore accelerate the development of
compostable workflows as well as the
definition of new machine learning
potentials
which ingredients are data descriptors
and learning methods
furthermore multiple dispatch can also
allow us to express object oriented
functional programming patterns
related to this the scientific machine
learning ecosystem offers packages such
as optimization shale
that brings together several
optimization packages into one unified
julia interface
this the conventional programming is
another important point it allows to
accelerate development by automatically
calculating
loss function gradients forces
sensitivities of quantities of interest
among others
it allows to calculate gradients across
multiple languages and simulation codes
and julia has powerful automatic
differentiation tools such as enzyme or
psychot
in particular enzyme meets or exceeds
the performance of state-of-the-art aed
tools
developments can be also accelerated
using hpc and machine learning
abstractions
for example flux makes parallel learning
simple using the nvidia gpu abstraction
of hula shale
sure actually is dynamically typed by
but with support uh for optional type
declarations it feels like a scripting
language but it can be compiled to
efficient native code for multiple
platforms
these were some of the things that julia
has to offer in this kind of projects
applying composability to the atomistic
ecosystem requires characterizing the
software components or main features
involved in their and their interactions
we identify what we think are the most
important high-level software components
involved in seismics organized in three
lanes or composable workflows
classical md avenue md and classical md
with active learning
combustible workflow 1 describes the
software components and relationships of
a classical md simulation
essentially at each time step the force
associated with each atom is calculated
based on the heteroatomic potential and
then used to calculate each new atomic
position
the correctness of the force on md
calculation is analyzed and reported
through the curved arrow components
to the dynamics model or control
component
so that this can be reported to the user
or corrective actions can be taken
in addition a compulsable design must
warranty the communication of all the
processes
for this purpose wrapper components
represented by small
circles in the figure are included in
the design
the wrappers are key in this design
because they allow iteration new
software to coexist in the same workflow
each wrapper implements a set of
interfaces associated with a particular
component
composable workflow too the bike's an
abinacio and the process it is mostly
analogous to the workflow i shall
describe but in this case the force
calculation is provided by a dft
simulation
composable workflow 3 presents a
combination of the lateral workflows
here potentials are forces are fitted
with respect to data generated by the
wire in the dft simulator
the fitting process can be complex for
example sub sampling could be required
and therefore requires a dedicated
software component as well as analysis
of its inputs in terms of errors
sensitivities etc
furthermore for the dynamics model
components based on the analysis of the
potential forces and molecular dynamics
can refit the forces in a process called
active learning
we already have
some a talk and some information about
atom's base uh this is a package created
by the people from julia mall
as michael said it's a lightweight
abstract interface for representation of
atomic geometries julian helps in the
operability of diverse itemistic tools
our software stack depends on this
package
we also already have a talk about dft
uh the ftk hal
other tools like quantum expresso
provide the dft data that will be fitted
in the atomic potentials and interatomic
basis potentials these packages create
abstract structures and interfaces for
common empirical and machine learning or
that even in atomic potentials the key
functionality is to provide access to
energy forces and stresses of atomic
configurations for each of the
implemented potentials
currently the implemented potentials are
leonard johns born layer coulomb cbl
morse snap a pure drill implementation
and a wrapper to ace or an interface to
ace one chair
new potentials are also being developed
potential for molecules and compositions
of neural networks with interatomic
potential descriptors
in addition work is been done on
efficient neighborhoods and gpu
parallelization
in particular we find gpu cardinals for
the potentials
currently the main dependency within
this project is atom space
in example on the left you can see the
integration with atom base where an
anatomistic configuration or system is
defined
then an empirical potential is defined
and used to compute the energies forces
and videos of the system
finally information about the new
created types and the computation of the
basis snap are presented
create your own potential something
interesting about multiple dispatch is
that once you install the software
packages you can extend them
in this example creating a new
interatomic potential without the need
of modifying the original package
in this case in the atomic potential
scale
once you define your new potential it is
automatically integrated to our system
there is no need to create a pr to
extend the original package
in this sense trulia facilitates the
integration of new software with the
entire domestic suite
potential learning
this is a package for active learning of
interatomic potentials like the older
packages it incorporates elements from
differentiable programming software
composability and hpc
in addition it will incorporate elements
from valencia and influence and machine
learning for better mining
optimal parameters as well as
uncertainties and sensitivities
this package offer useful functions to
process input data so it is ready for
training
for example read the xy is still filed
with
the atomic configuration or system
linearize the forces split dataset into
training and testing normalize the data
transfer the data to the cpu define
iterators subsample the data set among
others
also functions that simplifies the
learning process iterate through the
epochs and choose between different
optimizers and finally post processing
computation of different metrics mean
absolute error are square covariances
etc saving results and plotting
within this project this tool depends on
atom's base diatomic potentials and
interatomic basis potentials
this package is currently under refactor
and iteration process
a domestic share this package provides
an integrated workflow for nd
simulations it provides an interface to
moldy an embodied simulator that allows
to define and run the md simulation and
post process its results
atomistic cl is compatible with any
interatomic
potential that implements the abstract
interface defined by in the atomic
potentials shale
the core on the left shows an
implementation of the composable
workflow 1
that describes a classical md simulation
it is based on an argon system with 160
atoms and then i'm shown asymptotical
potential
the example integrates atoms based in
the atomic potential cl and the md uses
the embodied simulator
in case you want to work with moly
instead of mbs from the user perspective
only a few changes are needed mainly in
the thermostat and the definition of the
simulator
also this tool abstract the generation
of plots and of a lot of the simulation
results temperature different energies
radial distribution functions among
others
compostable workflow through two depicts
on avenida and the process where dft
simulation is used to compute the forces
the choice of parameters is for
demonstration purposes and the results
are non-physical again switching from
mbs to molly can be done by modifying a
few lines of code
lampshare is rougher to alarms and
allows direct communication without
round tripping through python the model
allows access to snap and execute an md
simulation
atomistic composable workflows
this repository aims to gather easy to
use seismics align case studies
integrating the latest developments in
the julia domestic ecosystem with
state-of-the-art tools
although this is a work in progress some
examples are ready to be used
in particular there are there is a
documented example about how to install
the automatic suite and fit different
dft data sets using ace run multiple cdl
parallel fitting experiments and run and
md simulation
these are all our sesame tools and
feeder integration efforts
in particular that are
are
very similar to interatomic potential
and potential learning so we will have
to integrate that this is the work of
another researcher of the project that
we want to um
integrate to our
suite
carom i think this package will be used
for sensitivities in particular
uh
you already know enzyme and
we we didn't start with the kind of
monte carlo yet but
this there will be an integration fort
as well with that
um
some software engineering practices i
mentioned composable workflows we are
using
github and i will show you our
repository in a second
we use continuous integration
documentation
visual studio code and
gluten outlooks
this is
one of the things that we want to do in
order to document
we start a lot in this interesting way
of integrating our tools using notebooks
you can program from your browser so
almost
uh you almost do not need to use the
console or more sophisticated tools such
as vs code the notebooks can provide at
the same time documentation tutorials
code and live results so all this in one
place
also you can use this is as a mini
laboratory and change small parts of the
code to test your ideas you can export
the notebook as an html file and use it
as a blog post finally this feature is
experimental but you can also run your
notebook in the cloud so you don't need
to install software on your computer
in case you want to see
our
repo
collaborate
or give us ideas is here
finally
um some dependencies i know my time is
up
so i'm going to quickly
finish here
that's it oh one more thing
uh if you want to communicate with
people from the center
uh
you can go to this webpage and get in
touch
uh with all the people that make this
project possible
thanks so much emmanuel this was this is
super cool to see how you guys are
already kind of taking a lot of the
stuff that that various folks have been
building and running with it um there's
one question in the pigeon hole that
that may be better better suited for
perhaps a slack discussion um kristoff
is wondering about um making
inter-atomic potentials um a community
run package um
due to sort of concerns about things
being just within individual research
groups or things like that um but i
think perhaps that discussion would
would be best head out uh over the slack
i think that's that's really you know
maybe we can we can follow up later yeah
yeah yeah but let's let's discuss it i
think i think there's there's some great
points there um
uh oh there's i just see one new
question
um
oh uh kristoff asks any comment on
enzyme versus zygote versus valentine's
new package forgot the name
um
i'm not certain which one that is either
uh the new position i don't know uh the
enzyme versus zygote
i mean if you want to work with
interatomic
machine learning with atomic potentials
and you want to use flux flux is
integrated with zygote
enzyme is not yet regulated
with flux uh so
um working with that this is
one of the things because i'm not using
enzyme right now but i hope to use uh
this package in the future because i as
i said it meets or exceeds
performance of ad tools and
state-of-the-art tools
yeah i've definitely heard some exciting
stuff about enzyme as well all right
cool so let's
endeavoring to stay not too much more
than four or five minutes uh past time
uh we'll bring gustavo in here um let's
bring his screen share up
and i think we are good so you can take
it away gustavo okay can i
yeah we hear you great all right great
uh
so first of all happy to be here and
thank you rachael uh rachel for putting
the work to organize this
uh so my presentation would be a little
bit uh different from the rest uh i
figured um
it's a julia khan
conference so i want to focus really on
on the code and more pragmatic so
because of that i decided to
just have a notebook so we can run some
code together and you know that you know
when you run code in front of people
there's a lot that can go wrong so let's
just hope that i don't look like a fool
here
um
and
uh the first thing let me mention so
what i'm what am i presenting on i'm
presenting on fermi
fermi is a package or at this point an
ecosystem
of three main packages
uh they are designed so you can run up
an issue quantum chemistry simulations
um so by that i mean uh currently we're
focused on wave function methods so
it's different from the previous
presentation that you you you learned
about dft
and let me first walk you through the
the packages that we piece together to
build firming so the first one is
molecules
and it is a very simple
package that basically deals with
uh creating this atom structures so
right now this is what we use
uh instead of the atom base um
there's some discussion we need in order
to integrate that with uh what the
community has been developing
uh
but
this is what gives us the basic
structure so here i have some example
uh you can import molecules and if you
want to read uh you can either read a
file or just parse a string in this
string you're familiar xyz
and
you can just run this and it parses into
just a vector of atom objects okay
um you can also create a molecule on top
of that but it's not mandatory because
the idea of molecules.jl is that
it it it doesn't really need any
information about the electrons once we
go to fermi it's all about the electrons
so we're computing the wave from the
electronic wave function but at this
point we're just caring about the nuclei
um so there are some properties that you
actually only need to know the position
of your nuclei um
to get for example well i said the
molecule you can create a molecule right
here and this is what your molecule look
like and and then there's some
information that is assumed about the
electrons such that you have charging
multiplicity um
you can compute the repulsion between
the nuclei you can compute for example
mass and then this is something uh
cool the
have two colleagues working on in this
point point group symmetry
so
uh you can run this on water for example
and you get the um
and you find out what is the point group
that that molecule belongs to so we're
we're doing this because we're the goal
is to build uh to the point that we can
actually run up initial computations
using point group symmetry which is
important if you have small systems and
you really want to throw some heavy
theory at it
so in that sense i think there's a big
difference from fermi
to the other packages that
we've been uh
seeing so far because here we really
focus on the molecule
vacuum small systems and we want to get
as precise as we can
uh in the description of the electronic
uh
behavior
okay and then the second package that
comes after this gaussian basis
um
and this is the package so it uses
molecules right it takes molecules as a
dependency and this is the package that
will handle integrals so you know if
you're running
up initial
computations
it all boils down to integrals over some
sort of base set that you're using in
our cases we use gaussian bases
or gaussian functions as the building
blocks of the wave functions
um and there are two ways currently we
you can do this you can use we we wrap
uh we have this wrap around the c
library called libsynt it's very
efficient it's very good and that's the
default that fermi uses
but we also have a very very very simple
julia library
and
if you want efficiency you should go for
lipstin but if you want flexibility you
could use the julia library and that's
um
what we're using for example at this
point for automatic differentiation that
i'm just going to show very some very
early results at the end time allowing
um all right so gaussian basis you're
going to import that and you can
construct a base set just by telling
giving me the name of the data set so we
have
uh many standard basis set that you can
find on the set exchange um and then you
just pass a molecule okay uh there are
many
many ways you can construct that that's
just one way
uh and you construct that and you see
here and by default you're gonna get a
spherical as opposed to cartesian basis
and your back end will also be linked to
lipsend that is just because you know
you need to chew up the information a
little bit before you can make a c call
so that's why we have a
back-ends defined at this stage
uh
all right and once you have your base
set then you can just call whatever
integrals you're interested in so for
example overlap and you call that upon
your set object and you get here
your uh overlap matrix um
another one for example this stands for
electronic repulsion integral and we
want two electrons on four centers so
that's uh
the integral that you might be used to
look at uh
c represented is this
this okay
and we can run that
and you get this tensor this two by two
by two by two because that's the how
many basis functions we have we have
only two very simple example
um the problem with this is that there's
a there's a lot of redundant information
in this array so it's more common that
we want element wise by element-wise i
really mean
shell-wise
because that's how it is computed so you
can pass here the index of the shells
and
it only gives you that particular
element so um if you're looking for
efficiency you really don't want to
compute the full the full array uh and
you see this
this one one two two would be this
element right here okay that's another
way to call so there are flexible ways
that we want to create so you can use
this package
um
you can also create um so in these lines
i'm just creating an atom right here
okay and you can create the basis
function object itself so i have
basically set objects and then i have
basis function objects
and the basis function object you only
need to pass angular momentum value
you pass the values of the coefficient
the expansion coefficients and the
exponents of your primitives
let's not waste too much time here but
you can create that i have a
cool representation of it and you can
fetch the values
as you normally would for any object
um and you can that gives you
flexibility for example here i'm
creating this vector of atoms that i
showed before uh it's gaussian basis is
really just calling the molecules
package and then your basis uh your
basis set is really the most primitive
data type that is stored in there is
just a vector of those with those basis
functions right each associated with one
atom okay and we can run that and we get
here your very exotic phases set where
you have two
uh
bases and one hydrogen and just one in
the other one so it gives you
flexibility to do that type of thing
now we move to fermi
and i want to be really quick here um
i'm not really going to talk about
performance we have a paper out where
you can get a very academic discussion
um
on it uh the the takeaway the the
take-home message here
is that it performs quite well uh
there's hope for it and it's nice to
write code in it we all know that
because we all here kind of using julia
for a reason
but i
now um
uh first of all let me show you
this is the basic basic usage of fermi
you can define a molecule you can set a
few options basis set
do you want density fitting or not you
want to use dyes or not and then you can
just run your rhf and your results you
get a nice output with the information
about the iterations
and um the orbital
the summary with your orbital energies
and your final harsher fog energy right
here uh we also have more refined
methods of course
the best one being the
ccsd princess team method you can run
that
and here
the output is a little bigger but um
basically we'll have your harsher fog
being performed first
then your couple cluster iterations
right here um so you do your couple
cluster doubles and then you do the
perturbative correction
uh for triples down here and you have
this
refined energy
okay so that's the basic usage of uh
farming
now
what i really want to talk about is
uh
something that it for me is one of the
the the reasons why julia when when
people ask the question why would you do
this in julia and it has to do with the
flexibility and and
the cool way you can just extend
packages extend
functions and it all
builds upon the multiple dispatch system
that julia uh uh
takes as this main paradigm of the
language so
in this example i'm gonna create a
harcher [ __ ]
code which is completely fake you're
gonna see here that i'm just generating
so if you're using line i'm taking this
um
uh which
i didn't declare the type here but it's
supposed to be an integral helper so
it's just a helper to fetch integers and
i'm running my fake heart to [ __ ] by
generating some random uh
array for the
uh orbital coefficients some random
numbers for
for orbital energies and then the energy
is just the sum of the orbital energy is
returning that this is just of course uh
just so we have something to work on
here
um if you want to learn how to do an a
proper hard to fog
uh in
our git repository there's uh another
notebook
where you can uh walk through and learn
how to implement the real hardship not
this fake one right here so
and implement that and uh
let's just
uh
to border here let me we can run that
and oops
i have a
your helper let's just create an
integral helper
uh i forgot to make that capital and
as we expected there's a bunch of random
numbers okay
um
now um
oh i was doing this down here what a
fool
uh
but now what we really want is to
integrate that for me right that's the
whole point here
and how you do this is by
that's a default thing in julia you're
going to import
the functions that you want to extend
so here there are three functions or
three
in this case this is more like an object
um and i'm gonna explain how those
things work together
to make this uh uh nice uh extension
possible so let's import that
okay
now um
this is a new harsher [ __ ] of course
fermi has hard to [ __ ] implemented
already
but we we build that such that it's it's
flexible enough that you can pick an
implementation so we can have several
different implementations of the same
method okay for each implementation we
associate this singleton so this very
simple structure it's an empty structure
um
that just kind of acts as a flag this uh
the the the
guides the code using mutual dispatch to
the right implementation so that's what
i'm creating here i'm creating a
structure which is rhf uh some type of
rjf algorithm
and this is another key step this
function that i imported here
it it's it's it's something that's
called the dispatch by value
so it takes a number and depending on
what that number is it returns something
so here i'm saying if this function
takes in the number three return this
object okay so we can actually try that
out
get r jeff so
you can see if we put the number one
it returns this is the standard uh
harsha [ __ ] implementation so if you put
number two
that's the second hard to [ __ ] which is
direct how to [ __ ] and then the third
one is the one that we just created okay
uh now here um
i'm now
working with this piece right here which
is uh how fermi expects the the archer
file to be called is with this function
which acts as a constructor for the
object the rhf object so here i
implemented two the first one just takes
that singleton
okay uh it creates a integral helper and
passes that along to this next one right
here and you can sort of read this uh
uh
later but it's basically fetching a
bunch of things that you need to
construct the rhf object that's all
what's happening here so i'm not going
to waste too much time
and let's see now we can
now here i'm running fermi i'm not
running the function up there i'm
setting the rhf algorithm to number
three and then i'm going to run hard to
[ __ ] and you see
this is the line that i had right here
my fake heart your [ __ ] energy let's
return this random number and it returns
right here it's a hard to [ __ ] object
okay so um
sometimes i i present this to people and
you go
just over their heads but the cool thing
here is that i'm creating a new
implementation
totally orthogonal to fermi i never open
firmly source code to to to produce this
do to
put this new code in there so this is
really
plays with fermi's main goal of being a
development platform so we can play
around uh without fear of breaking
everything down and also it's gonna play
well as long as we have this object
right here farming knows how to fetch
information out of this and use in other
computations so for example we can do
mp2 right here
and it's just going to do to do them to
perform an mp2 computation you need a
harsher file computation so
it first runs the
large my fake rhf and then it goes
and runs an mp2 with that uh of course
that i'm getting nonsense here because
my heart [ __ ] is nonsense but it can use
it has no problem another syntax that
you can use for this is actually when
you call this macro it returns an object
the rhf object and then you can pass
this rhf object to the method that
you're playing with and it works same
same thing okay so just to finish up now
so this is the main thing that i wanted
to talk about is like
how nice is to be able to do this in
julia right and that's one of the main
reasons i decided to stay
but another thing is so a lot of people
talked about and that's something that
we a direction that we want to go
towards so here i have a very
preliminary result of our attempt to
integrate automatic differentiation into
fire me
uh we just got these results like
yesterday or something um so this is
again hard to [ __ ]
um
and a gradient so forces for for water
molecule just using a minimal base set
so this is by no means
a benchmark okay again look at this is a
very preliminary result and this is the
error against the analytical result and
also the run time against the analytical
result now you see the forward diff
so using automatic definition not only
we get something that is way more
precise
in fact it's exact
um
compared to finite differences but it's
faster which is something that i'm
worried about um
we don't expect that this is ever going
to be as as good as the analytic result
especially for archer [ __ ] because the
expressions for the heart of all
gradients are very neat it's it's not
you don't need to do iterations or
anything so it's impossible that ad
would outperform analytical results but
the fact that it's better than the
finite differences really make us think
okay it's worth it to pursue this for
methods
the
getting gradients is just too cumbersome
so this is the direction that we we
going towards and i think i've been
talking for 17 minutes so i'm gonna stop
right here and this is it
wonderful thanks so much gustavo just a
real uh a real tour de force in terms of
like cool julia tricks with
extensibility and id and and you know
new results from yesterday i love to see
it um
there's uh there's a brief discussion on
the pigeon hole which i think is another
one that may be easier to move over to
slack or even just the github issue
around
integrating molecules.jl and adam's base
i know there's there's already been some
preliminary discussion on that but um
i think uh
that that may not be something that that
makes the most sense to do live but let
me just come in the main difficulty that
has stopped me from doing that is that
it's just the different needs that
different packages have for us all we
need is the position and the charge
because that's how
because we're doing electronic
computations so all we care about is
like this point it's positive point
charges in space so i think atom basis
has more features right now
which is probably um
it's more than we need
so it's easier for adam adams base to
encapsulate what we have than the other
way around if that makes sense but we
certainly will discuss that and find a
yeah i mean i think we can we can
continue the discussion in terms of you
know what the advantages might be i i
personally think there still might be
some some exciting avenues and just
regarding enabling interoperability with
other packages yeah yeah well the first
thing i want is to make sure that things
work with either one of course yeah of
course yep
um michael herbst adds i guess this is a
more of a comment than a question kind
of question um it says a quick comment
regarding ad i don't think it's
impossible to get even the same speed as
analytical gradients if you're willing
to write the appropriate custom rules so
maybe that's that's worth noting if you
want sort of a unified approach to doing
these gradients if you if you implement
those behind then i i don't have a proof
for i say but i think for heart shaft it
would be very much impossible because
when you do a d a d is running with all
during the iterations the hearty [ __ ]
durations
the the gradients for hard to [ __ ] you
don't run iterations it's just a one
step it's a one shot so i think it would
be very hard to outperform that
fair enough um
again i think we can this is what the
slack is for if people want to continue
any follow-up discussions but um
okay michael disagrees um but uh we can
we can continue this perhaps uh well not
offline but but online in a different a
different online um so uh
again to stay uh
a constant or relatively constant delay
behind schedule uh let's let's switch
over to kristoff here let me uh have him
go live um let's see okay we need to
remove gustavo's
screen
all right i think you are ready to go
good stuff yeah we hear you great
thank you for organizing this and i'm
effectively taking over the organization
uh julia morrison
um so so i i could start
apology for the last three weeks and my
older son drowned my laptop my brand new
m1 so this is
kind of hacked together very last second
could just live back once a day um so it
might be a bit chaotic but i'll do my
best to to to
uh to to keep it more this on track um
so
the the main product for me for the past
several years now and
also
part of the reason to to to work with
julia is
is this
is this this model atomic cluster
expansion um so somebody asked earlier
so what kind of
um
ml models are there for uh that that you
can dedicate
to atomic structure in atomic potentials
and force fields and this is this is
sort of one of the the main ideas that
are sort of coming up in the in this
community
um and i'll talk a bit about
our our work on that so so for that
purpose i'll i'll actually first talk
about what is the atomic cluster
expansion
um and and as we've talked quite a bit
about what purpose is this so the
purpose is coarse graining of course
right so you
you you want to mimic a high fidelity
model uh through some some interesting
bit more
and um
at a specifically we use cost so i in in
the case of interatomic potentials is
effectively what you want to do is you
want to start with an electronic
structure model uh and then but then you
want to put of course in a way electron
instruction information and only keep
the mechanics because that's the only
thing you you you need to actually run a
molecular dynamic simulation
um
and there are many many ways nowadays
how to achieve that very effectively and
the moon that we've been working on is
the atomic cluster expansion i'll give a
one slide summary for that so that that
people have seen this it's it's a it's a
beautiful simple model i i think it's uh
it's um
it's almost an inevitable model it's
it's how how natural it is
so so the the first step in in this and
this is necessary to take step but this
is this is common um
that you do that first is that you
uh you have a potential energy uh
surface
so cap
is the section of positions of atoms you
could have other features in there as
well but i'm not going to track them on
those slides and that you first
decompose it in space that you assign uh
to each atom a
energy
um and that site energy could depend on
a small atomic environment
the way interatomic potential force
would always works
and so then rather than prioritizing the
total energy you parameterize the site
energy
um and that that's where the term atomic
comes from um so what do you do step one
is that you project the atomic density
um so so the way uh this is often
described is that you uh you you you see
some at some ra and then you're looking
at all the neighboring uh relative
positions and and you you create a
density of that and then you project
that density onto
some basis and and in language of ml you
would call this an embedding
okay so so now the problem with this
embedding is uh that
it it it has some features you want for
example uh it it it is invariant under
permutations of the neighboring atoms
right so that's that's great
um but it's not invariant yet and
under other symmetries and specifically
the to the symmetry you you care about
in this
in the setting is that that is your site
you must be invariant under rotations
and reflections so that's what we mean
by that
and uh and and sort of the the idea on
how to fix this comes from um
comes signal processing and so so what
people have done there is
that you you first form the n
correlations
um a very good reason why you have to do
this that i don't have time to discuss
so that means you're taking tensor
products of the energy of the of the of
this this density and project that
tensor parts of your basis functions
and in fact uh in in my language of
numerical analysis i don't do signal
processing what you what you would call
these objects is simply a
basis
of permutation invariant polynomials
provided your
these these functions there are
polynomials so so will will these be and
and and so but you still don't have the
invariance on the rotations in there but
you can get that by simply averaging
uh so you take the
uh we we now call the symmetrized n
correlations so you take the spaces of
permutation invariant polynomials you
average it over all rotations and
reflections and then that gives you
features or in fact you know again in
the language of the emergence of
approximation theory a basis of
permutation and all three invariant
polynomials and using those
in parameters
these site energies
so that's just the basic idea there are
many many more tricks in there um the
the most important one uh is that if you
choose the right basis here namely a
tensor product in radial angular
components where the angular component
is described by spheric harmonics then
this average can be expressed explicitly
as a linear operation and this this just
uses the irreducible representation of
o3 that that's what the ylms are
um
and uh there's a bit of work to really
you know make this work effectively but
um but it can all be done and so sort of
and that that basically this model that
i'm showing here that is what we've
implemented and have done a lot of uh
research on
okay so
how i'll start with a
very quick demo i i really hope you have
a big screen because i think these fonts
are very small so how do we how do we
work how have we implemented this this
is now
uh
in ace dot jl
uh so first how do we describe uh
particles atoms right uh so so for
we have type called state
and and it can have various features for
example if you like in like before
the only feature an atom has is is the
position then you say okay say it only
has a position
uh as a feature and then then here you
see the state but but you know you might
you might want to give it some
additional features such as the the
atomic number um or you could use the
symbol for the species itself
um
uh you might want to give it a char
magnet whatever
this state object here is is basically a
just a
wrapper around named tuples and it gives
you a lot of flexibility in in in
constructing
atoms or gen general abstract particles
that have uh whatever features you want
them to you want it to have
okay so now next thing it is the the
embed
so
it's it's this uh the density projection
right so so on on the previous slide i i
call this
uh phi and lms
um
so so you can define this right you have
you have some way to define a radio
basis the the ylm basis and then you
form products so that that gives you
uh it gives you the bedding for for
these
for these features
right because you
uh
because basically they they uh
they're a way of of of um
they're basically a way of expressing
this extensive projection i had on the
previous slide right that's that's
that's what that was
okay so now we have that we have that
um
from that
from this one particle basis from from
the density projection this defines you
can now uh create the the symmetric
basis
the uh symmetrized n correlations we
call this here symmetric bases and so we
have to here is you have to specify a
few things first of all you want that
your
output
is invariant
right so you want you need to specify
this embedding here and you want to
specify with respect to which group
you're you're you're symmetrizing so in
fact that there are other groups one can
specify
um then you also define which basis
functions you actually want which of
these many body basis functions you you
really require
um
and so now once you have a basis now you
can you can uh you can create a a linear
model for for
the the
the site or atomic property you want
right so so
you give them to some some parameters um
you're just choosing random parameters
rather than fitting them um
so now and that model cannot be valued
on an atomic environment an atomic
environment is is simply a collection
of atom positions right or possibly atom
positions with features i'm not
as it is
uh and then you can evaluate your model
on that atomic environment and then from
that that's the basic starting point now
from this you can then of course take
gradients second gradients you can uh
you can sum them up to the total energy
you can you can do whatever you want but
this is sort of this is the very basic
structure and just to to show what will
really happen behind here the
centralization
with respect to permutations and and o3
um you know if i for example if i if i
rotate the all the positions here and
that's what's happening here
and then i evaluate the mod on the road
positions you get exactly the same
number here so maybe one more little
comment here is the iron front it
indicates that the output is an
invariant that's related to this here
yeah
um
and so so we always keep track
what properties the the uh what
what what are the properties we're
constructing what symmetries do they
have that's sort of that's the key point
in all of this
okay uh
i will think i will skip this
to not waste more time okay so very
quickly
there's a whole suite of codes around
these basic ideas
so i do i just showed what hl does um
the predecessor is
which used to be called asgl which which
is
more stable and and sort of more user
oriented whereas gl is really very much
working progress um and and has far far
far more features and i maybe if i have
time to to get to that oh by the way
rachel i uh if if you're just fueling me
uh and i three minutes before i should
stop that i'd be very grateful okay uh
but this is these are just sort of the
two core packages and around that there
are several others uh for example uh ace
one pack is uh is written to be as user
friendly as possible whereas these are
really more
for developers uh ace atoms that's um
that's our interface to construct
interatomic potentials i'll show you sec
that we don't construct can't just
construct invariant properties but also
equivalent properties and with that we
can for example fit hamiltonian
operators
and then there is a there's a package
that supports the the parameter
estimation process that's ace fit um
it's flux is something fairly new where
we're trying to
go a little bit go away from these
linear models and build more non-linear
models this is again very much working
work in progress
and then there's one more package i want
to mention made
this is essentially the state of the art
for
machine-learned interatomic potentials
and unfortunately that's not written in
julia and that's maybe part of my
discussion very end but it's related to
everything i'm talking about
all right
uh so now
a second demo to show a little bit about
all these these
these these satellite packages
um
so so here i want to actually fit an
actual interatomic potential and just
show you
how that you can do this with just a few
lines of code so so so here i'm just
putting a date file and then
this is an xyz file
uh
that uses a
what is called xyz.jl
that reads in
training data it analyzes the training
data it gives you summaries right you
can see here oh i have found two kinds
of structures in there one is called
filter l the other one is called thai lt
500 5000 i forgot what the first means
but this here means that this is that
aluminium training day at 5000 kelvin
so most likely md data um and it
contains 14 such uh structures uh in you
know in total 100 atomic environments 14
energy observations three thousand three
and seventy eight fourths observations
and 126 variables observations and
that's the data to which we can fit
okay so we generate an ace basis right
so this is now a short short version of
what i showed you on the previous slide
uh okay which species
appear right we'll see what's the body
order it's actually the correlation
order so body order minus one that you
want what's the cutoff radius and then a
few other parameters that are important
in practice you want more than just this
mint body a spaces you also want to add
on a pair potential a parameter
potential
pull together a single basis and then
you can start hitting uh so you uh you
know this this is a this is a script i
want to go to the details so i can move
on but basically you you you specify
what are the weights and the different
structures you specify whatever you want
to use uh what prior you want to use and
so on and so forth and then you you you
you run at least squarespeed because
it's a linear model or all of this
actually runs in 20 seconds on my
uh my three four year old laptop that i
just stuck out yesterday
so so it possibly models
this is extremely is extremely efficient
um you you
you can you can play with them and they
get very close to state-of-the-art
all right uh
so here
this would probably be about the three
minutes to go or so so we can have a
little bit of time for for questions and
discussion afterwards
perfect
uh and then the there there's machinery
also to to to to to to perform tests and
so on so forth
so uh i'll what i'll maybe do then is
skip the aquavariant part
which i expect that i would have to um
just a few more so with these ace models
you really you can get very very
accuracy
uh
at fairly decent performance so so here
we are uh we're seeing a a really one
state-of-the-art silicon potential
so refitting a train set to develop for
for the gap model um basically the same
accuracy but much much faster um
i'm going to skip the molecules this is
something that isn't it published but
this is completely stunning for me that
this can be done and this can only be
done because we have these extremely
efficient fast linear models that allow
you to do sampling efficiently and and
so so this is now uh okay one two three
four component alloy um and a fully
automated uh construction of pace
diagram for a four component alloy um i
think maybe this is something one needs
to be the full talk in more detail but
but but but these are the sort of things
we can we can we can with these
you can actually do real science that is
that's the main point i want to want to
make it's not just a sort of a toy code
to play around with
all right uh so i i'm gonna skip this
but uh
the main point is you can construct
equivariant models as well and
uh it
it's as easy as invariant models
everything is sort of made
as uh
as as accessible as user-friendly as
possible i wouldn't say it's yet that
user-friendly but that's certainly our
goal
um so let me just but but just that con
so
once you can construct equivalent models
then you can for example
fit hamiltonian operators this is
something we've done so we're
creating the self-consistent uh dft
hamiltonian so that you can basically
skip the scf iteration but they're much
more exciting applications of this as
well um so in two more recent work so so
we're starting to approach wave
functions so we use this atomic cluster
expansion to parameterize to construct
efficient wave function representations
and the last one that i'm extremely
excited about not quite the domain of
this
of this of this symposium but um
is jet tagging so this is analyzing
experiments from uh from super colliders
um
and all of this can be done within the
same framework
so it's really very general and very
flexible that was the whole idea okay so
then i'll what i'll uh what i'll do here
is i'll just have a few final comments
um to discuss sort of what i'm thinking
right now where i'm uh what we've been
do what i found did not work so well to
to maybe get some input maybe help if
anybody's interested
so the first comment was on atom's base
why we adopted that yet well basically
uh because nobody amongst my
collaborators really cared um and
i didn't have the time so so that that's
what i'm we will in the future uh but
before this becomes useful for us we
would really also need a community
package to have prototypes not just for
for for for
for apps and structures also
for for the the operations you perform
on them um so i really hope that we
could we could agree on something like
that
uh i think
none of my collaborators uh use use
julia to actually run simulations they
will use ase or lamps and that's about
it uh there was some discussion about
moving to molly i think that
sense was this isn't ready yet um
for for what they want to do we'll see
if we get there soon um hopefully
so i i wonder if there is some energy in
this community to create interfaces that
we can share
um i found it incredibly hard and
frustrating to to get uh robust python
and c plus interfaces they they usually
they they run for maybe a million times
steps and after 2 million or 10 million
crash the second and we have no way of
finding it the third comment i had was
um sort of this this hgl package i spent
a lot of time with the past few months
making it more composable and then
differentiable right and and and it was
very it was not easy to do this while
keeping the performance that i had in my
original ace package so there's this is
not very much to work in progress and i
i'm very interested in hearing people's
experiences
on on ad which which way everybody's
going
and then finally the same
gp basically we've given up on that for
now and that's the reason why the
multi-layered version of ace that's been
developed over the past few months was
not written in julia it was very bad
about that but this was written based on
pie torch and
i hope very much that i can catch up on
that and again i'd be very interested in
those views and um
and have a discussion about
possibilities here so i'll stop here and
uh if there are questions that didn't
follow then i'm happy to talk about them
of course
great
maybe i'll start with the one the
question we have in the pigeon hole so a
fairly i guess nuts and bolts question
how long would it take to calculate
forces and energies for a thousand atom
system using ace are simulations of
biomolecules feasible
right uh so so biomolecules
there is a there's a caveat in that
right if you want to run biomolecules i
think you it it you
you it's a sampling problem actually
right
optimization or something like that
uh so so
latency is a big issue right um so but
let me let me maybe uh let's with what
is the cost of it of a high accuracy ace
model um
basically
it's in the range of 100 microseconds to
millisecond for for the highest
would want to achieve accuracy you if
you're willing to sacrifice accuracy
you'll go down of course in cost because
it's a linear model you become any
features you want that the actual skills
nearly
um but for the for the sort of
state-of-the-art accuracy models you
have to estimate 100 microseconds to 1
milliseconds so so that that's
uh it's real on a single cpu so one once
you but once you parallelize so so you
can multiply that by one thousand right
but then you if you do that that gives
you a good estimate right
but i think biomolecules the real issue
is latency and uh so so if you have a
large system and you want to you need to
to sample you need you need millions and
millions of times right as you
unless unless the latency is right i
don't think
you you can you can do that and i
um
we can have more discussion on that that
does that the question
uh as far as i can tell it does um
michael also asks i have not so much
battle-hardened experience on the python
to julia side but julia call seems to be
doing a lot better than the previous
solutions
um have you tried that
uh that is on my agenda very much so
i've uh i i will definitely try that
i've i'm kind of
i i i i find i cannot do everything on
my own and so i'm bugging my
collaborators to do this and and
hopefully some will pick that up and
find out because they're as frustrated
as the sex faults as i am
so this will definitely one of the next
things we will try
great and uh but so before we move on i
think that all the thoughts you have on
this slide here i think are are so so
important if you don't mind i've taken a
screenshot of it and i was just going to
drop it on the slack because i think
there's a lot of follow-up threads here
that would be really really good for
community discussion and hopefully we
can get some some momentum around
addressing at least some of these in the
near future i think to me part of the
like there's so many there's so many
subtle questions around you know
you know i mean adopting adam's base for
instance it's like well of course you
shouldn't do it just to do it we hope
when we make adam's base that it that
it's appealing enough because it enables
other things but you know it's on us
ultimately to convince you that that's
that that that's true and then and then
to also kind of make it make it as easy
to adopt as possible and i think that's
true with a lot of this stuff around you
know clearly there's there's a
compelling case for things like ad for
things like these things and and so so
it's it's deciding that it's worth doing
and then also figuring out you know what
the best approach is and definitely i've
certainly struggled with some ad stuff
um particularly in the package the the
around electrochemical rate modeling
that'll that i'll show later in the week
um i think that's
it's something that is
you know it may in in along certain
dimensions be really best in class in
julia compared to other things but i
think it's it still does suffer from
being a little bit young and and
immature in certain ways that um it's
not always the easiest to actually make
it happen even if it works well once you
do um and i think there's there's a lot
of good discussions here
um that that hopefully a lot of people
in the community will will engage with
so i thank you for bringing up all of
these um
related to all of this before i
move on so so we most of us write these
two packages as a research course we
experiment and it's it's it's fun we
make fast progress
but to really make an impact we need the
users and the users are not injured and
going to be anything soon
um so so i i really think making what we
do
accessible
to users and by by that having
really standardized robust interfaces to
ase and lamps would be the start i i
think that would make such a big
difference
anyway i think no i think that's a great
point i mean yeah i'm personally
extremely optimistic about julia as a
major part of the future of scientific
computing but obviously that that future
is not yet here and it's if if we want
to get a foothold i think i think you're
thinking in exactly the right way i
think i'll i'll definitely be interested
to follow up on several of the ideas you
have here afterwards and see if we can
maybe get a uh some community momentum
around building these i will say at
least in the adam's base case
probably the coding that actually built
adam's base and michael can chime in
here
and joe to some extent too probably took
place over
maybe two weeks honestly like the thing
that took a long time was was the
discussions and figuring out okay what
do we wanted to have what do we want it
to look like what would be you know what
is the most sort of flexible but still
achievable thing that we can build and i
think it's it's those discussions that
hopefully this community will help
enable um and and we can come to some as
you say come to some kind of consensus
and really um and then and then move
forward and actually build these things
um so so yeah i absolutely agree um but
let's um let's uh continue a lot of this
on slack i hope um again everyone
everyone please feel free to jump onto
that slack workspace if you're not
already there um but for now i'm gonna
hand it off to james
um so we will thank you uh thank you
very much kristoff um okay and here is
james video and his
screen okay i think you are good to go
james hello
cool um
great well yeah it's great to be here
thanks um rachel for organizing this and
i think um yeah we've obviously raised
some really good points so far
so um
so today i'm going to talk about um aqc
dynamics which is a package that i've
been working on during my phd studies
over the past um
probably a little over a year um
and that this is based on doing
non-adiabatic quantum classical dynamic
simulations which i appreciate is a
fairly niche topic so i'll give a
hopefully a good introduction to this so
you can all follow along so we've heard
a lot about classical molecular dynamics
kind of simulations we do in molly and
these rely upon
a single ground state potential energy
surface which is a function of the
atomic coordinates and this relies upon
the the born oppenheimer approximation
that states that the electrons will
adjust instantaneously to the motion of
the nuclei this can also be referred to
as the adiabatic approximation but in
some cases like in like atmospheric
photochemistry for example so this is
like the photodissociation of ozone in
the atmosphere um you can get
like explicit electronic excitations
um due to the interaction with light and
in that case the ground stay born up
behind the classical dynamics is no
longer
going to accurately describe what's
happening
and additionally you can see similar
non-adiabatic phenomena
in scenarios like a molecule metal
interaction where in this case uh kind
of different to the
um the gas phase type photochemistry you
have um
many closely spaced potential energy
surfaces due to the like um the many
many electrons in the metal and the the
small spacing between the states can
lead to lots of like small excitations
where the motion
of the nuclei the translational
vibrational motion can couple to these
electron hole pair expectations
so
ideally we'd like to be able to treat
these with classical simulations because
we know these like scale very
effectively with um with the number of
degrees of freedom people have done
absolutely massive classical and dynamic
simulations like big biomolecules and
things like that however um
we need some way to to be able to
include the these electronic excitations
so one of the most popular ways of doing
this
are surface hopping methods
and these these involve running
classical dynamics on a single potential
energy surface the same way that you do
for classical molecular dynamics but
then when you enter coupling regions
um you can hop to different states and
this hopping
is based upon
integrating the time dependent
electronic schrodinger equation
alongside the the classical nuclear
dynamics you have coupled electron uh
nuclear motion and then when the
amplitudes become significantly large
you can hop to to other states and then
that's that's allows you to include
these non-adiabatic effects
then
in addition to this surf stopping
methods you they're also mean field type
methods or air infest and these
similarly to surface hopping you will
integrate the
electronic schrodinger equation
alongside the classical dynamics but
this time the force doesn't come from a
single potential energy surface this
time it's an average over multiple
states and this again is based on the
electronic amplitudes
and another different way of doing it is
these mapping hamiltonian type methods
and these will
map the electronic coefficients
onto
onto continuous classical variables
and this is quite nice because it's a
very purely semi classical method and it
allows you have a a single classical
hamiltonian that you can
use to drive your dynamics and you're
treating the electronic and nuclear
degrees of freedom on the same footing
and then the final method i'll mention
today is
electronic friction so this is focused
on that
molecule metal
scenario i mentioned before
and that here you you run classical
dynamics on a single potential energy
surface but then you include the
electron hole pair excitations by
adding additional drag and and random
force like you do in the lunge event
dynamics but this time the for the
friction coefficient depends on the
position
and is related to the electronic
structure of the metal
so all of these methods are included in
nkc dynamics
so when we created nqc dynamics we we
had a few goals in mind one of them in
particular was to
kind of encourage a stronger correspond
between scientific publications and the
code that is available because at least
in this field in particular
sometimes it's not entirely clear how to
implement these things and people may
that sometimes don't seem to be inclined
to release their code um so so we've
tried to make like publicly available
implementations of a lot of popular
methods and hopefully this will
encourage other people to do the same
and in doing so we try to keep a very
modular structure so that it's easy for
other people to add new stuff and this
is a nice thing about junior in that
because you can
create your new package and like hack in
any way you like to someone else's code
and start adding extra pieces it's very
modular and will allow people to
to add stuff but also like retain
ownership because some people you know
aren't entirely on board with the whole
open source thing and that's that's
totally fine but we've tried to
facilitate that as well
and then and then another main goal
was to
make it easy to to develop methods and
go from small model systems to full
atomistic systems because a lot of the
time
people will introduce a new method and
benchmark on a small model where you can
get exact quantum results
um and see how well your methods
performing but then a lot of them never
quite make it to the point of going to
full semester systems and i guess a lot
of the barrier here
could could come from the fact that it's
really hard to get these like excited
state potential energy landscapes that
you need
but also
the the added barrier of having to
re-implement your code um can be another
obstacle we've tried to
remove that barrier
so
now i'll give a package overview and
we'll talk about the different
components and what a simulation might
look like so the first thing you have to
consider
and this is the same for any like
classical dynamic simulation as well my
initial positions velocities and then
you also have to consider your
electronic variables as well so we have
this initial condition sub module where
we've implemented a few things like
monte carlo sampling or thermal length
dynamics so you can generate like a
thermal equilibrium equilibrium
distribution sample from
and um at the minute for the electronic
variables we just have like you're in
one state or or another state and we
don't have any explicit sampling for
like thermal occupations but that's
something we we definitely will do in
the future
so once you've got your initial
conditions you can then
run your dynamics
so
for our dynamics we're using
differential equations.jl which is
obviously a big success story of julia
and
we kind of we very much
deep um deeply relying on a lot of the
stuff that they're doing and our our
ensemble version uses their ensemble
machinery as well which is nice because
it gives us
a lot of the stuff they've already done
like the
the outputs that come out and when you
do an ensemble you can average and
reduce the outputs as you go to say
you're having to process lots of data
after the fact
so then internally
we um
we have this dynamics method sub module
we're in there that's where we're
defining all the dynamical equations
that differential equations expect
and then the other main component would
be
nkc models which we've packaged
separately and this kind of touches on a
lot of the things that have been
discussed earlier about
um like potentials and um and actually
our interface is quite similar to the uh
the interatomic potentials that was that
was mentioned earlier in sessmix
but the difference here i guess is that
we need excited state landscapes and
couplings as well so it's a slightly
different um niche to some of the other
things that been mentioned but it would
be cool if you can find some kind of
unified way of doing that
so to put this into practice then i've
put in a small
example script of what a simulation
might look like
so this is just going to be a
one-dimensional two-state scattering
problem
which was first tackled in this um one
of the original surfshopping
publications so we have a single
particle with a mass of 2000 and then
our model that we're going to use is a
two state
more that looks like this where these
black lines are our adiabatic potentials
and the red line is the non-adiabatic
coupling between them so when our
particle moves in from the left when it
reaches this region it can hop between
different states
so we've collected our parameters here
and then and this specifies the type of
dynamics that we're going to be doing so
f ssh stands for fewer switches surface
hopping which just is just a particular
variety of stopping which is very
popular
so
the next thing we need to do is specify
our initial distribution so here we have
a initial momentum of 10
and a position of -5 which puts our
particle about here they're moving to
the right
and then um we just kind of collect
these things together in the dynamical
distribution so this type's quite useful
because here we're just using a single
position and velocity but you can
actually
put in like vectors of different
configurations or you can
have in like sampleables from
distributions.jl as well
and this final argument just specifies
the size of the sample so here we've got
one dimension and one atom so it's just
one one
then this bit on the end is
the electronic distribution so we're
going to start in a pure state on state
one which is what our particles down
here and we're in the adiabatic
representation which you don't need to
worry too much about but it's just it
means that we're here and not not up
here
so
the the next thing to consider is what
what the output of our simulation is
going to be so i've kind of cheated here
a little bit and i have a pre-made
function that does exactly what i wanted
to do but in theory here you can just
write any any julia function that takes
the differential equations solution and
outputs something from it
but this like will
take in the solution and give like a
ones and zeroes depending on whether
it's scatters or um or transmits and
which state it ends up on
then
we're gonna average over many
trajectories so we just add the mean
here and then because we're averaging we
need to specify like the output format
that comes out so the this thing i've
made before will give us a component
vector with a reflection and
transmission component where each part
has
two states
because we have a two-state system
so finally we can we can run the
simulation we um specify time span how
long we want it to run for and then we
just add in everything we've already
defined earlier uh the only thing we're
adding is that we want to do 500
trajectories
so when you run this you'll get an
output that looks something like this
where we do our 500 trajectories and it
takes some some length of time
and then at the end this is the output
that we get
so
i mean this isn't particularly exciting
we've got like zero percent reflection
and
pretty much 100
uh transmission on the ground state
which is the state that we started on
but if we were to redo the simulation
lots of times for different incident
momentum we see that it looks a bit more
interesting so the simulation we just
did was
um was at 10 and you can see this green
line t1 transmission on the ground state
is 100
but then
if we redo a higher momentum we see like
some interesting pattern occur where
we're seeing some uh like transmission
on the excited state here and there's a
tiny little bump here
with um reflection on the ground state
as well
and
we can directly compare this to
some of the plots that were in this
initial publication
and although their x scale is like a log
scale of energy you can see that we're
roughly reproducing the pattern like
this blue line looks a bit like this one
and similarly for the green line and we
don't quite get the full spike here
which we see with this um this red bump
but i think that's just because we're
under conversion i just took this plot
from the example online so if you are
interested in seeing how exactly you
create the plot i mean it's pretty much
just doing that the previous simulation
in a loop but um but yeah so this is
cool because we quite easily just
recreate some published results
obviously it's for just a small
model system
but but you got to start somewhere and
really the cool thing is that
if you want to
go to higher dimensional systems the
input script looks pretty much the same
you just have to modify a few things
so in the future one of the one of the
big things i'd like to improve is the
the user experience so in that example
hopefully it didn't seem too painful it
seemed
fairly ergonomic
but um obviously i'm working with just a
one-dimensional system so when you go to
atomistic systems you do have to
at the minute you like go through ase to
load in your structures and you have to
convert it to the right format so
obviously the the solution to this is to
connect to the atom's base ecosystem and
i'm particularly excited about uh
michael's students and their atomizers
hopefully they come out with something
good
because i'd definitely be interested in
using that so yeah that's something i'll
definitely be doing in the future
and then i guess the eternal goal of
this package will always be to add more
add more stuff add more methods because
i don't know there's probably tens of
methods like this out there maybe not
hundreds but definitely lots and i i
would very much be interested in
including loads so it's very easy to
compare between different ones and just
by modifying a couple keywords here and
then so in particular at the minute
we're working on this independent
electron surface hopping which is a
variety of surface hopping they're
focused on these meta metallic systems
where you have lots of electrons and
you're hopping them all independently so
that's quite cool
um
so with that then i'd like to thank you
all for listening and i think thank uh
people for funding my phd product and
other people in the mail group
particularly oscar down here um he he's
been like running lots of simulations
doing lots of testing for me so that was
quite nice and we have a paper down here
if you're interested in reading about
this in a more academic format
and of course you can find us on github
where we'd be very interested in
in uh contributors or comments issues or
all kinds of things and i guess if you
are interested in this kind of work you
can get in touch with um with our group
at warwick like my supervisor here
reinhard would probably be interested in
talking to you if you're looking for a
phd or something
cool thank you
thanks a lot james uh just so cool to
see the ways in which the the
packages out there are growing for for
all different kinds of atomistic methods
so so
um very neat to hear something in a
simulation method that i am aware of but
certainly have never have never worked
with and yeah i think probably a lot of
people have like heard about it at a
conference someone mentioned it once or
twice but unless you um
actually in the field it's quite easy to
pass it by it's not something like
machine learning that follows you
everywhere
yeah absolutely so um thanks for sharing
the the only thing i see on the pigeon
hole right now is from mark who says
suggestion contact the rapids folks
about gpu integration um i am not
personally familiar with what rapids is
something to google yeah
um
cool uh maybe i'll give another little
bit in case anyone i
stuck the pigeonhole link up again in
case
anyone else has other questions um
obviously uh you know i i know james is
on the slack so so further follow-ups
can happen there too nice yeah he's
about to wreak havoc over here
um
and uh
cool all right well um thanks a lot
again i don't see any other questions
coming in so maybe we'll transition over
to sort of the last phase here of these
kind of quick pitches i think kristoff
has already done a phenomenal job of um
of of sort of informally kicking off
some of this stuff um with with the
wonderful points that he brought up um
at the end at the end of his talk and
i've i've already sort of tried to seed
some of these discussions over on the
slack um but maybe this this can be
another jumping off point for some of
those um so uh given that i'm i'm here
and talking maybe i'll um i'll kick it
off and then kind of pass the ball over
to other people so um the the idea that
i had had just in terms of another way
to to sort of keep the community in
touch and and um
and continue sort of engagement and
collaboration was some kind of uh
community seminar series and i would be
very very open to discussions around
what the format should look like how
frequent it should be i guess frequency
would probably depend on sort of level
of interest and engagement but i think
there have been a lot of really kind of
creative formats that i've seen for
these webinar series um if anyone's
familiar with the um the cyaml series
that has been run out of my group um
there's been some a cool format there
where there's sort of half talk half
like code demo
um i think you know ongoing community
discussions are on some of these some of
these interface ideas and sort of trying
to sort of build consensus i think could
be another another use use case for
those kind of touch points and check-ins
um
we obviously have a range of time zones
represented here um i think maybe not as
huge as some other collaborations so so
i'm confident we could we could probably
at least with the crew that's
represented today um hopefully find a
feasible time and and if not you know
take use make use of of recording and
and okay you
you're very cute but you're a little bit
disruptive right now um
make use of recordings and kind of
shifting around the times and all of
these things um so
yeah so that's that's my quick pitch um
very very open to further discussion and
kind of gauging interest thoughts on
format all of this kind of stuff over on
the slack i'll uh i'll start a thread
over there
um
right after this um for for any further
discussion friend if anyone wants to
wants to offer any thoughts on that um
and then i think um since i see that he
is here i'll i'll maybe hand it over to
pranay um he's gonna talk about some
preliminary efforts he's made for a
visualization package um
based on uh using adams-based systems
which uh was was something that i was
really excited about as something that
in particular that adam's base could
enable enable so
i'm really excited to to hear um
the the progress that's been made and
and you know what ideas he might have or
or
need for need for help or contributions
so um would that uh take it away for
tonight yeah thank you
uh so my name is johnny vignesh i am as
joe mentioned earlier i'm uh i'm a
jsocster and i'm working on mali.jail
and
this really kind of stemmed as a by
byproduct of that because we had an
issue with molly working with mackie
um so what i really noticed was kind of
missing in the julia molson community
was this sort of fully julia based open
source visualizer for molecules and
simulations
uh so really kind of there are existing
software for like vmd and ob2 for for
working with visualizations of
like molecules and simulations
but i think there's still a lot of scope
for improvement in terms of just keeping
things well documented uh sort of trying
to accelerate it and keeping things open
source and maybe sort of you know easily
extending it to kind of the systems we
want to work with
uh and also really seemed like a really
nice way to extend uh
the abilities of atom space and chem
files um
so really sort of the goal of a
visualizer like this would just be to
uh be able to
have some visual construct for all the
things that are registered on julia
molson so if you want to like for
example optimize a structure on dftk and
just maybe uh like look at it
uh you can just run a simulation or so
you can just sort of look at it with
with our tool or if you want to see it
on a simulation on molly and just find
out what the trajectory looks like you
can uh sort of use our tool again or if
you maybe want to test some inter-atomic
potential or some force field on julia
maybe you can just use this tool
directly
uh so
the point really is that you don't have
to work on hassles with you know plug-in
plug-ins or like file writers or readers
you just have a julia full julia
interface so if you if you have
something that comes from julia then you
can just work out of that
uh so i i just started a very basic kind
of rustic repository on github called uh
called sclera
s-c-l-e-r-a you can just search for it
on
uh github and your verifying my
repository and it just uses mac here to
kind of just plot out molecules uh and
right now just it doesn't have much
capacity basically just scatters a bunch
of atoms and it weights weighs those
scattered points
uh by the atomic masses
uh so right now it just works with
inputs from chem files and inputs from
atom space and and some of the uh so so
really the point is uh that you don't
have to install separate plugins or use
specialized tools or sort of work with
weird file writers or readers you can
just directly use julia and use this
tool uh without worrying with all of
those frustrations
uh so there's still of course a lot of
concerns that we have since we've just
started this package so one concern for
example was uh drawing bonds so so when
you're working with files that have
uh bonds specified like multiple files
or pdb files you have fonts explicitly
specified
uh you you can just draw lines between
those points
uh but when you don't have bonds
explicitly specified uh then you might
want to sort of come up with a scheme to
do this so for example like xyz files or
if you're working with an atom space
system where you haven't specified the
bonds we need to come up with a sort of
a way to do that
and uh there's been some discussion but
we still want to like figure out
explicitly how we want to do it so for
example if you have a carbon carbon if
you have two carbon atoms in in your
system uh when you sort of draw a single
bond when you search for a double bond
do you do you need the uh
the atoms to come to a certain cutoff or
you just want to specify explicitly so
we just kind of need a discussion on
that
so
that's basically
all that i have as of now but uh it's
it's just something that we need to work
with the community right now because
we're hoping that
people would really suggest
uh
implementations are uh based on what
they want to see within uh
the within their julia simulation so if
they have something with respect to a
molecule they can just use this package
and it depends on what they need
so it the best way to sort of extend
this and to work with this would be if
maybe there was a hashtag visualization
on on on the slack it would be really
great maybe but it would just be like if
based on whatever
uh needs are there for this for the
community on visualization you can just
be post on the slack and you can have
discussion and just work on implementing
that because right now i think what
would be really great if if just people
put out the ideas of what they really
need in visualization
uh so that's basically all i have to say
for with this regards to this is just
hoping to get a lot of to put this issue
out there on working with visualizations
in atoms so that the community can kind
of get involved
so yeah
great um awesome so i i put a comment um
with a with a link to the github that's
that's pinned to the screen right now
ask and you shall receive i just created
a slack channel uh and invited you
pranay and uh any anyone else should
feel free to join um as i mentioned this
is this is a direction i'm really
excited about i think this is a very
natural
um a very natural direction to go in to
have something where we can you know
similar to how some of us might use
ovito or vesta or something right now
very you know agnostic to file format to
what kind of system it is be able to
just plug it in um i think i think
that's a a really huge value add to the
community so so thanks for kicking it
off thanks for the creative package name
um and and let's hope that there will be
some uh continued um engagement either
via via the github there or um
and or on slack so so thanks a lot for
that
so uh next i will turn it over to jose
um
who's gonna talk a little bit about a
package he's been working on i think
yeah
hi everyone
uh i think i can share my screen which
i'll try now
hope it's working
so
for my phd i started developing
protozoan
and it's a molecular manipulation
simulation package very similar to what
we've been seeing today here i actually
started working on this in 2018 so a
little bit before atoms based or perhaps
even molly i was interested in doing
protein design
so protein synthesis hence the name
and if you've done protein design before
you probably heard of rosetta it's
incredible software
which is written in c plus plus with the
wrapper in python
but we wanted to try something new like
some crazy weird confirmations
modifications and even energy function
components and
you know there are a lot of problems
with uh
with existing tools like that so for
example there are low-level programming
languages they don't have
very good documentation
uh
they're also like for example rosetta is
before gpu was something that everybody
had available so there's no support for
that sort of technologies and they're
often like not open source
so that's why we did we did producing
julia seemed like a perfect fit and you
know it was a modern approach it
fixed the two language problem which
existed with rosetta it had a growing
community of users
we focused a lot on creating good
documentation and tutorials
we included native support for gpu
acceleration using cooler.jl
distributed computing from julia native
stuff
now
i'll just go quickly over the features
um
so this is a completely molecular
manipulation suite so we can do anything
we want to a molecule right we can add
sidechains remove them cut them copy and
paste them craft
parts from different uh proteins
together
i will we'll be focusing on proteins but
it's not like necessarily proteins it's
it's agnostic can work for everything
um then we want to do simulations with
this stuff right so we need
uh energy functions we have all the
normal common stuff
um like you know restrained potentials
or generalized porn
uh solvation energy stuff like that
but
you know making energy functions it's it
is hard it is really hard so we wanted
to
give that work to someone else we wanted
this to be
as as easy as possible to plug and play
with existing tools for example we
implemented the ref 15
energy function from rosetta
and
we also
we also did some something with torch
ani if you've ever heard of torch on is
a eft train machine learning potential
on uh train train we're using pi torch
so use pi call to call that
that potential
um
and then we can do all sorts of
algorithms um we do not do molecular
dynamics that's that's what molly exists
for it's mostly
you know iterated local search monte
carlo kind of stuff
which is a little bit different
and then of course there's a lot of
features that
i don't have much time here so i'll just
i'll just focus on the last one here the
ramified and weird structures so
it's something that we wanted to explore
and we couldn't do with the other
existing tools so we
here we can do ramified stuff like sugar
polymers glycoproteins cyclic peptides
non-canonical amino acids so really like
weird stuff made easy
we also use the seam computing which
greatly increases performance especially
when we are working with smaller
proteins
normally the overhead of putting things
on the gpu actually doesn't
doesn't allow for very good performance
when comparing to to sim
and then finally the documentation it
was something that we felt was really
necessary and so we really focused on
having like very good examples tutorials
and a full documentation website using
document.jl
now this is just some under the hood
stuff which i won't go into very detail
here's a very quick example we can see
how we can like take parts from
different proteins craft them together
uh cut loops out and then you know copy
a new one in and then do a quick monte
carlo to close the loop
um
using torch ani and generalized born as
the energy function to evaluate that
loop closure simulation so
it is a complicated thing but as you can
see it's like 20 lines of code
so i think the api is actually pretty
good i would say
some interesting use cases include for
example doing protein folding
of course that nowadays with alpha fault
this is you know
not very
competitive so to speak
but it is a fully physics-based energy
function and we can derive confirmations
down to four angstroms in rmsd
we actually have some newer results
which we go lower than four angstroms
for small peptides of course
but it is it showcases that the energy
function and the
conformational search engine is actually
kind of working
so the future we want to further develop
protozoan of course
um since the
the rise of atoms base we've seen this
as a very necessary thing to do to
integrate with this with atom space
it is something that we would like to do
in the near future
and then of course to grow a community
see what people are requiring what sort
of things do current
solutions do not
do not do and that protesting could do
we've had
you know for example the non-canonical
amino acids was something that was
requested because
existing tools couldn't do it and in
person that's super easy to implement
so yeah i think that's it i think i
showcased uh
perusing more or less
uh
hope that made sense
um it is it is a an old so to speak
project
before
all of these all of these new
technologies started to emerge in the
julia community
so so to speak it was it was like a
parallel development
and and also it was just me doing it for
my phd me and my supervisor i'll be
finishing the phd soon so you know if
somebody wants to take over protesting
and like
develop these mother carlo applications
for something useful
feel free to to engage and
i'm always happy to to talk about this
stuff
very cool thanks so much jose um
i don't personally spend too much time
thinking about biomolecules but as far
as i can tell this seems like a a really
cool set of features for for those folks
who do who i know there are there are
several uh presenting and listening here
so um very cool stuff um the other
person we have giving a short
presentation for this last segment is
leticia
so i will
let her i see she has an appropriate
background for a bunch of computational
folks it seems like she's sitting in a
server room
i will let her
take it away and uh and talk about what
she's been working on thanks a lot for
being
thank you for the opportunity dr rachel
curtin i would like to share my screen
is it possible
uh yep go for it if you if you start a
screen share then i can i can add it to
the broadcast so just um
yeah go ahead
and just so you know what you probably
want is share screen there's also a
share slides option but that requires
you to upload something so probably just
share screen is the way to go
yeah i i cannot find the
link to share my screen
uh
i mean it should be your you're
obviously on the stream yard i think
there there should be a button that just
says share
and then there's like when i click it
there's a couple of options that come up
there's slides extra camera video file
and share screen at the bottom so if you
just click share
and then hopefully there's a button that
says share screen
oh i think it's because i am
through my mobile phone
uh okay all right okay
i can i can present just talking without
my
life
all right go for it sorry about that
sorry for it
thank you again for the opportunity
uh
i would like to
present today my package call it quantum
phoca it is already available
in github i am a
just
braided
chemist
i just got my bachelor degree in
chemistry and i am an undergrad student
in computer computer sciences as you can
see in my server room
the idea of the package is to solve
the schrading equation using the
ohata method to calculate the molecular
integrals and the most curious fact
about quantum parka is that
the name
comes from
an idea that i had between the two
languages i am brazilian and in
portuguese a seal
is
ah
and it is inspired by another
electronic structure software that has
a
marine animal in in the name so it is a
fun fact about quantum focus
uh our focus in phantom foca is to solve
the molecular integrals using the ohata
method by the fastest way you can find
in other packages so
it is interesting because
we have tests and you can see it in the
repository that
rachel has
shared the link with you all in the
comments
and
the tests comparing
quantum focus
to calculate heart to fog
energies and copper cluster energies
show that
quantum focus is faster than
orca software
which is really impressive
after the the new implementation of
shark model in orca
and
i have ideas for a near future
the main idea that i have is to
implement the mcmarty davesand method to
calculate the molecular integrals
and use the atom's base system
to interact
between the gaussian base to interact
gaussian bases and molecules
and
get the
data that we need for the calculation
more easily
for the calculation you only need to
provide the xyz files the charge of the
molecule and the spin multiplicity
it is quite easy to run it is just
import
in your
raffle
on your judo rebel
and i am open for contributions and i
hope that you have
understood
the presentation and if you have
comments questions you can find me on
github on twitter
and
all your comments and contributions in
the repository are very welcome and
thank you again for the opportunity
sorry for the i really apologize for the
tax problems
um
and it was a really
really good symposium
many ideas here to share to hear and to
learn
and really excited to contribute more in
the project song
or all the presenters that have showed
the work
and thank you again
okay
thank you so much leticia very cool um i
will say um especially given there was
the slight difficulty with sharing the
slides there if any speakers want to
share um slides or or uh you know code
the demo code notebooks whatever
feel free to send me those and i can
make i can update the the org website um
with links to all those resources if
people want to follow up or if you just
want to put them on on your own github
repo somewhere we can link to that
very flexible whatever you'd like to do
so so feel free to send those along
i've pinned the comment with the link to
join the slack again so just to
reiterate um you've heard me say this
several times already in the last few
hours but um if you know that that's
there's already been some amazing
follow-up discussion on several of the
of the points that have been raised um
over on the slack workspace so um
do do get connected to engage there
check out our github org it's just julia
mulsim very easy to find
and yeah we're we're just about to the
end of the time so thank you again all
for listening um
thanks thanks especially to all the
presenters um who who shared who share
their really cool work um i'm i'm very
excited to to be a part of pushing all
this forward i i
you know bumps in the road as they are i
think there's i think there's a
tremendous feature for julia in this
space um and i'm really excited to be a
part of it with all of you and um
yeah thank you again for your attention
um
let me just check the pigeon hole one
more time in case there were any final
comments or questions or anything um
i don't see anything so um
yeah i think i think that's it thank you
all for your again for your for your
attention and your participation and uh
have a great rest of your day bye